Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 146. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle aufs herzlichste, die wieder reingeschaltet haben hier beim Express. Und ich kann heute auch mit nicht ohne Genugtuung verkünden, dass ich es jetzt endlich geschafft habe, hier mal wieder so ein Hardcore-technisches Thema auf die Matte zu legen, an dem ich jetzt was weiß ich, was ich glaube schon seit einem halben Jahr säge, um da endlich mal den passenden Gesprächspartner zu finden und vor allem vor das Mikrofon zu bekommen, damit man das hier mal so ein bisschen besprechen kann. Soweit ist es nun gekommen. Also, das Thema ist JavaScript und ja, ich begrüße für diese Sendung den Malte, Malte Ubl, hallo. Ja, Malte, super, dass das geklappt hat. Wir sitzen hier im schönen Hamburg und ja, du hast ja schon mal ein bisschen was gemacht mit JavaScript.
Kann man, glaube ich, so sagen.
Wie lange bist du denn überhaupt schon im, wann hast du denn deinen ersten Computer eingeschaltet?
Das ist gar nicht so lange her, vermutlich so 1990 ungefähr.
Okay.
Und Programmieren mache ich so.
Auch schon 20 Jahre.
Ja, leider. Seit 1994 hacke ich irgendwie Kurzzeilen in den Rechner. Damals habe ich angefangen mit Smalltalk und das so gemacht bis ungefähr 1998, dann ganz viel Perl.
Welches Smalltalk, den ich fragen darf?
Ja, Visual Works, genau.
Wo ist das zwei oder was?
Ich habe in der Firma gearbeitet, die das irgendwie ganz groß gemacht hat, mit Deutsche Bahn und Mercedes-Benz. Und die brauchte eine Website und dann habe ich angefangen, so Websites zu bauen. Und das hat man ja früher mit Perl gemacht, weil das irgendwie so war.
Eigentlich die erste Web-Script-Sprache in dem Sinne, die da war.
Und dann auch schnell ganz viel JavaScript und auch irgendwie entdeckt, was damals noch nicht so wirklich entdeckt wurde. Ich möchte es fast wirklich so formulieren, weil das oft so bei Programmiersprachen entdeckt wird nach vielen Jahren, was man damit alles so tolles machen kann. Und man sich so von Babysprache entwickelt, so richtig coolen Sachen. Und weil ich halt irgendwie von Smalltalk kam, habe ich natürlich versucht, objektorientiert mit JavaScript zu programmieren und das auch gemacht. Dann wieder verlernt, weil niemand anders auf der Welt das gemacht hat. Und dann ging es ja wieder so, weiß ich nicht, Anfang 2000, 2002, 2003 richtig los.
Ja, es steht definitiv ein Revival dieser Sprache, die es eigentlich schon lange gibt, aber die, wie du schon sagst, lange eigentlich missachtet wurde, steht irgendwie an. Das lässt sich an vielen Zeichen eigentlich ablesen, auf die wir sicherlich hier im Laufe der Sendung noch zu sprechen kommen. So geht es mir auch, deswegen wollte ich das Thema auch unbedingt mal auf die Bühne heben. Aber du hast ja jetzt nicht nur JavaScript gemacht, du hast ja auch Erfahrungen mit anderen Programmersprachen gesammelt.
Ja, ich habe fast alles mal angeguckt zumindest. Professionell war es Perl und C-Sharp und Java und so alles Mögliche. Auch mal ein bisschen Lisp und was es halt so gibt auf der Welt. Irgendwie mal durchgeguckt.
Aber hängen geblieben bist du bei JavaScript oder hat das jetzt nur Businessgründe?
Nee, das war fast das Gegenteil von Businessgründen. Vor ein paar Jahren hatte ich mehr so einen Management-Job und habe dann festgestellt, dass ich abends nach Hause gekommen bin und noch mal vier Stunden lang JavaScript programmiert habe. So zur Entspannung. Genau. Und dann habe ich irgendwann die Konsequenzen daraus gezogen und gesagt, mache ich es auch wieder tagsüber, aber so ist das halt gekommen.
Also du hast einen ganz guten Überblick. Einen Überblick sollte man vielleicht jetzt auch erstmal gewinnen und zwar vor allem erstmal, was glaube ich ganz wichtig ist, also bei JavaScript ist es glaube ich fast noch wichtiger als bei anderen Sprachen, was eigentlich so passiert ist, was diese Sprache überhaupt ins Feld geführt hat. Womit hat es denn überhaupt angefangen? Was war denn das erste JavaScript, wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
Das war Brandon Icke, das hieß auch mal anders, ich glaube erst Mokka und dann LiveScript und dann kamen halt die Marketing-Leute von Netscape und weil damals gerade der Java-Hype losging, haben sie halt das Umbindendeal mit Sun gemacht, die dann im Gegenzug Java mit Netscape halt distributiert haben und dafür durfte dann der Java verwendet werden. Die Sprache hat aber gar nichts mit Java zu tun, außer dass sie beide von C abstammen und in Syntax mehr oder weniger kopieren an vielen Stellen und man ähnliche Namenskonvention benutzt, aber so im Wesentlichen war es dann auch mit Gemeinsamkeiten und so ging das los. Ungefähr so 95 war das.
Mein Eindruck war, dass das ein ganz schöner Fehler war.
Die Benennung?
Diese Benennung, weil eigentlich…
Das hat natürlich falsche Erwartungen.
Genau, das kann nie gut sein, gerade nicht bei Programmiersprachen. Aber ich kann mich noch ganz gut erinnern, damals, als es halt in der Diskussion war, der Hype war halt Java und dann kam irgendwie dieses JavaScript hinterher und es fühlte sich irgendwie an, wie naja, das ist aber weniger, dann können wir ja auch gleich richtiges Java machen. Das denke ich mal halt bei vielen Leuten, die sich nicht wirklich damit beschäftigt haben, auch so im Hinterkopf gestanden. Na gut, aber es war halt da und es war in Form eines nicht besonders schnellen Interpreters im Netscape Browser eingebaut und eigentlich auch nur da.
Genau, wobei dann ja relativ schnell die anderen mitgemacht haben und die Implementierung in IE, also Internet Explorer, die heißt ja JScript und kam, ich weiß nicht genau, aber dann doch relativ fix und mittlerweile ist es halt sozusagen die einzige Programmesprache, die irgendwie überall drin ist. Also das ist ja auch der ganz große Unterschied. Also man kann sich ja auf der Server-Seite irgendwie lange drüber diskutieren, was man nur einsetzen will, Geschmackssache, Ruby, Python, Perl, was auch immer, PHP vielleicht sogar. Aber im Kleinen ist es halt JavaScript, da gibt es nichts anderes. Und das ist natürlich eine Riesenschance und einfach auch cool, sozusagen so eine einheitliche Plattform zu haben.
Aber das ist noch mal kurz bei diesem geschichtlichen Verlauf bleiben, weil gerade diese JScript-Geschichte, weil damals die großen Browser waren am Start, Microsoft war ja nur nicht gerade besonders bekannt dafür, jetzt unbedingt von vornherein auf Kooperation zu setzen, schon gar nicht in dem Feld. Inwiefern unterscheiden sich denn JScript und JavaScript? War es denn im Wesentlichen schon dasselbe oder gab es wieder so kleine gemeine Unterschiede?
Also es gab lange die Wahrnehmung, dass es Unterschiede gebe. Das ist aber, im Grunde stimmt das gar nicht. Also die Wahrnehmung auch dieser schlechten Qualität der Vorgangssprache war primär dadurch beeinflusst, dass die Interfaces zum Browser, also vor allem das Document Object-Model sehr uneinheitlich implementiert waren und dadurch erschien der Eindruck, die Programmiersprache selbst sei auch nicht generalisiert. Das ist aber einfach nicht so, also der Kern der Programmiersprache hat natürlich gewisse Abweichungen zwischen Implementierungen, die aber wirklich minimal sind. Also ich habe, ein Teil meiner Historie ist ja auch so ein Metaobjektsystem gebaut zu haben in JavaScript, was sehr umfangreich ist und im Grunde die ganze Sprachbreite nutzt. Und dort ist, glaube ich, sogar nur eine einzige Stelle drin, wo auf die Implementierung geachtet wird. Also so standardisiert ist die Sprache.
Und was wird da hin und her geschaltet?
Da geht es darum, was passiert, wenn man den, wir kommen da sicher später noch genauer zu, aber den Prototyp eines Objekts nachträglich ändern will.
Okay, also sozusagen tief im Kern des JavaScript-Objektmodells oder JavaScript-Typenmodells steckendes Detail.
Aber die Sprache als solche ist komplett einheitlich implementiert.
Es kam dann auch in der Folge zu einer Standardisierung durch die ECMA. Das ist die Standardsorganisation, die immer keiner kennt. Heißt das eigentlich auch immer noch das, was es früher mal hieß? European Computer Manufacturers Association? Ich war damals auf jeden Fall sehr überrascht, dass die sich dieses Thema annehmen. Gab es da eigentlich einen besonderen Grund dafür?
Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber der Grund ist. Dass das ihr Flagship-Product ist und sie sich ganz gut um JavaScript kümmert. Zumindest versuchen sie das. Auch wenn der Prozess in den letzten Jahren überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Aber im Grunde kennt man die fast nur, weil sie JavaScript standardisiert haben. Und es gibt ja auch Leute, die nennen das ECMAScript.
Das ist nicht gerade populär der Name.
Nee, der ist scheiße der Name. Das fand ich ganz gut von Douglas Crockford, dem Erfinder von Jason, der auch mal im Vortrag meinte, klar, Sprache ist zwar ECMAScript, aber das ist halt ein scheiß Name. Deswegen nennen wir den nicht und nennen sie JavaScript.
ECMAScript heißt auch nicht mehr das, was es mal hieß. Und heißt schon seit 94 nicht mehr, wie ich es gerade sagte. Jetzt heißt es nämlich gar nicht mehr, jetzt heißt es einfach nur ECMAScript, ohne irgendwelche Bedeutung. Na großartig. Okay, auf jeden Fall ist das eine in Europa ansässige Standardisierungsgruppe, die sich auch mittlerweile immer mal wieder gerade dem Thema Programmiersprachen annimmt. Was ja auch, Programmiersprachen Standardisierung ist ja eigentlich auch eher so ein relativ neues Konzept. Ich meine, es gab zwar immer bestimmte Standards innerhalb von Programmiersprachen, die aber dann im Wesentlichen so von der Programmiersprache selbst definiert wurden oder zumindest von irgendeinem gebildeten Gremium, aber selten von so einer Standardsorganisation. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie es bei Kobol ist, wer eigentlich diese ganzen Kobol-Standards festgelegt hat, aber was weiß ich, C, okay, da gab es irgendwie ANSI C mal, aber sehr vieles ist da nicht passiert. Hier scheint es aber dann auch wirklich besonders wichtig zu sein, dass man hier…
Genau, man braucht ja Standards, weil wir zumindest auf absehbare Zeit in der Welt leben, wo es immer mehrere Implementierungen geben wird und deswegen lässt sich da leider nicht darauf verzichten, von diesem Standard abzuweichen. Wobei ja vor allem, das ist aber eigentlich auch die einzigen, die Mozilla-Leute relativ viel mit der Sprache auch experimentieren und auch bereit sind, Sachen aufzunehmen, um mal zu gucken, wie die so sind, während alle anderen Implementierungen extrem konservativ sind.
Das heißt, die Mozilla-Implementierungen haben noch extra Features?
Ja, relativ viele und...
Auch welche, die Sinn machen oder ist das alles eine Spielerei?
Nein, das macht schon Sinn, die viele andere Implementierungen sind im Augenblick in einem totalen Speed-War und deswegen sehr, sehr konservativ Sachen in die Sprache aufzunehmen, die in irgendeiner Art und Weise gewisse Optimierungen dann nicht so optimistisch durchführen lassen.
Das heißt, sie sind erstmal ganz froh, dass man so diesen erreichten Standard hat und konzentrieren sich einfach um die Beschleunigung. Wobei, da haben sie ja auch schon einige Fortschritte gemacht. Da kommen wir sich gleich noch zu. Was mich jetzt nochmal interessieren würde, ist, also wenn JScript und JavaScript dann doch am letzten Ende dasselbe waren und sich eigentlich nur darin unterschieden haben, wie sie in den Browser eingebaut waren und dieses spezielle API zum Browser, auch bekannt, als schon gesagt, von Document Object Model, sozusagen ein Objekt-Modell, eine Selbstbeschreibung des Inhalts einer Seite, die der Browser dieser Sprache quasi anbietet zur Bearbeitung, wenn ich es richtig deute. Wie unterscheidet sich denn das jetzt von der Flash-Welt oder damals ja noch Makromedia-Flash-Welt, die ja mit ActionScript auch eine JavaScript-ähnliche Sprache hat? Wie ähnlich ist sie? Ist es dasselbe?
Nein, es ist nicht dasselbe. Ich habe auch sehr viel damit gearbeitet. ActionScript 1 ist im Wesentlichen JavaScript. Da gibt es keine nennenswerten Unterschiede, außer so strange Sachen, wie nicht case-sensitiv zu sein und so. Aber es ist sonst halt JavaScript und insbesondere ab ActionScript 2 und vor allem ActionScript 3 ist eine Implementierung von einem Vorschlag für JavaScript, was jetzt 2.0 oder 3.0 ist, wo man damals dachte, dass das irgendwann auch in den Browser ankommen würde, und was glücklicherweise nicht passiert ist, weil ActionScript 3 sozusagen Erweiterungen hat, die in die Richtung geht, eigentlich den Sprachkern aufzuweichen und eine statisch typisierte Poké-Sprache daraus zu machen. Ich glaube, dass es durchaus auch Sinn gemacht hat für Flash, weil um deren Plan war, zumindest mal so komponentenorientierte Entwicklung zu machen, und da macht es ja Sinn, dass man so, wenn man so einen Property-Dialog für eine Komponente bauen will, dass man so ein bisschen da reingucken kann in den Quellcode. Was hat denn das Ding für Properties, was halt in JavaScript nie gehen würde? Für die macht es also Sinn, aber ich bin da eigentlich ganz happy, dass das weggeschmissen wurde, der Plan. Deswegen sind die Sachen jetzt sozusagen komplett divergent, wobei eigentlich alle JavaScript-Programme noch in Flash gehen, aber andersrum geht es halt nicht mehr ActionScript. Ist nicht mehr.
Aber es soll doch jetzt wieder eine Vereinigung geben von ActionScript und JavaScript. Ist das nicht mit einer künftigen Version von ECMAScript geplant?
Nee, ist nicht mehr geplant. Also es gab eine Einigung, die wurde gepusht, vor allem von Yahoo und Microsoft, die sozusagen den Plan tatsächlich weggeschmissen haben. Man hat jetzt sozusagen einen konservativeren Einsatz, nur die Sprache so zu verbessern, dass es sich im Detail besser anfühlt, aber keine großen Änderungen vorzunehmen.
Und schon gar nicht die kompletten Änderungen, so wie sie bei ActionScript sind. Das heißt, ActionScript ist JavaScript, aber JavaScript ist nicht ActionScript. Und es wird in dem Sinne auch, es steht keine Vereinigung dieser beiden Systeme an. Das heißt, ActionScript steht dann doch noch sehr alleine da. Aber die Leute, die jetzt viel Flash gemacht haben und quasi in ActionScript gearbeitet haben, deren Wissen dürfte doch dann zum Großteil übertragbar sein in die JavaScript-Welt.
Die wissen, wie ich dachte, einer soll sich fühlen. Letztes Jahr auf der JSConf mit RGA gesprochen, eine große, bekannte Web-Agentur in den USA, die meinten, sie haben so einen riesigen Pool an Flash-Entwicklern, weil sie viel für Nike und so machen und da voll mit Flash unterwegs waren. Und die schulen sie jetzt alle um. Ich da war da auch anderer Meinung drüber, aber Flash wird einfach aussterben. Deswegen kann man da, glaube ich, auch nicht von der Vereinigung sprechen. Die Use-Cases brechen halt links und rechts weg und deswegen...
Das ist deine Einschätzung?
Das ist meine Einschätzung.
Flash wird da hinsichen?
Genau. Also ich habe fast so in meinem letzten Projekt die Rolle von Internet Explorer 6 eingenommen, weil immer alles nicht funktioniert mit dem Scheiß. Der einzige Grund, dass ich es persönlich noch einsetze, ist, wenn ich unbedingt einen Fullscreen-Modus brauche. Alles andere brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Geht das nicht mittlerweile auch schon? Ich bin ja die Tage über so diesen sublimen Videoplayer gestolpert, der dann dieses Feature auch...
Der kann das. Aber dort kann man halt nur das Video Fullscreen machen. Man kann nicht dem Browser sagen, man will Fullscreen.
Aber das ist durchaus davon auszugehen, dass solche Features auch noch nachgereicht werden.
Ich gehe davon aus.
In der nächsten Zeit. Das heißt, im Prinzip ist das Potenzial für JavaScript extrem. Weil wenn man sich mal umschaut, ich meine, Flashhacker gibt es eine Menge. Ob die jetzt alle im Wesentlichen am Skripten sind oder nicht Flash eigentlich nur so als automatisierte Abspiel-Animationsbude verwenden, wie das ja am Anfang gedacht war, sei mal dahingestellt. Aber ich denke, wenn man so halbwegs advanced irgendwas entwickeln will in Flash, dann muss man ja eh schon in die Programmierung reingehen, oder?
Klar, das hat sich ja auch komplett verändert, wie die Leute umgehen. Viele benutzen ja auch die klassische Flash-Umgebung gar nicht mehr, sondern sind eigentlich nur noch am Programmieren.
Also diesen Vergleich mit Internet Explorer 6, den finde ich ja sehr interessant. Gerade dahingehend war jetzt, ich war in den letzten Wochen gefüllt, davon, wie viele große Unternehmen jetzt Internet Explorer 6 gut beisagen. Google mit Gmail und ich glaube noch zwei, drei andere Ankündigungen. Ich erinnere mich gerade nicht dran, aber das Ding ist on its way out. Und ich glaube, Microsoft hat seinen Kunden jetzt auch mal empfohlen, das doch mal sein zu lassen.
Ich fand das ganz witzig, wenn Kollege Helge meinte, neulich mit Internet Explorer surfen ist, wie mit D-Mark bezahlt.
Irgendwie out. Und so ist auch JavaScript in Flash programmieren. Na gut, aber um Flash soll es nicht gehen. Jetzt, gut, es zeichnet sich jetzt schon auch ab, aus dem, was wir jetzt gesagt haben, was du gesagt hast. Das ist eine jährliche JavaScript-Konferenz, die war jetzt in der ersten Runde. Das ist jetzt auch eine JavaScript-Konferenz, die war jetzt in der ersten Runde.
Es gab die allererste JavaScript-Konferenz auf der Welt, letztes Jahr in Washington. Die allererste? Das war wirklich die allererste. Und das war wirklich ein Homecoming der Community. Die gab es halt vorher nicht. Man kannte sich irgendwie aus dem Internet, aber hatte sich noch nie getroffen. Und das war wirklich eine unglaubliche Veranstaltung. Auch sehr klein. Und alles nur die sozusagen Core-Entwickler von allen Frameworks. Die Leute waren sehr, sehr interessiert. Was war da so unglaublich drin? Na ja, die Stimmung war halt so... Das war so das Gefühl, es ist jetzt wirklich mal Zeit, dass das stattfindet.
It's about time.
Ja, es war wirklich höchste Zeit. Und deswegen hat es halt gepasst. Da wird eine Menge Energie frei, oder? Und wir haben im Bunde auch da noch, es wurde auch sehr viel getrunken, und wir haben halt noch in der Nacht entschieden, wir müssten das auch in Deutschland machen. Oder zumindest in Europa. Und haben dann, der Holger Blank und Jan Lehnheit und ich, haben dann gesagt, okay, wir machen es in Berlin. Und haben dann sozusagen jsconf.eu letzten November in Berlin gemacht. Jetzt ist demnächst wieder jsconf.us, die ist allerdings schon ausverkauft. Und wird auch wieder eine in Berlin geben.
Wo findet ihr die Stadt in den USA? Aber es wird dieses Jahr noch eine in Berlin geben?
Ja, es wird dieses Jahr noch eine in Berlin geben.
Innerhalb eines Jahres zwei Konferenzen? Beziehungsweise zwei Konferenzen in Berlin und dann noch die Konferenz in Berlin?
Nein, die in Berlin war letztes Jahr. War letztes Jahr in Rührenbayern.
Okay, gut, ja, stimmt, hast du recht. Ja, Jan-Leen hat was kurz erwähnt, war hier auch schon mal zu Gast. Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Chaosradio Express 125 muss an der Stelle noch mal erwähnt werden. Da ging es um seinen Baby, CouchDB. CouchDB selber ist nicht in JavaScript programmiert, sondern in Erlang. Allerdings, wer zugehört hat, wird es auch schon wissen, spielt JavaScript auch in dem Produkt eine gewichtige Rolle, weil es eben quasi so die Embedded Language ist innerhalb des CouchDB-Servers, mit dem man dann seine eigentlichen Datenbank-Transaktionen steuert im Detail. Und das ist auch ein ganz gutes Beispiel dafür, wie JavaScript so an ganz vielen Stellen in diesem Web so langsam seinen Urstand feiert. Aber natürlich ist es nach wie vor am wichtigsten im Web-Browser, ganz klar. Und da hat sich ja auch eine ganze Menge getan. Es hat sich eine ganze Menge getan in der Zahl der Implementierungen. Es hat sich auch eine ganze Menge getan bezüglich der Performance. Diese erste Implementierung in Netscape hatte einen, die hatte doch auch so einen Namen, oder hatte die keinen? Ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht. Was war denn die erste Implementierung, die einen eigenen Namen trug?
Also das ist Spider Monkey. Das ist die originale Implementierung. Und die heißt halt auch immer noch so, dass es die, die in Mozilla drin ist. Da haben wir natürlich viel dran gemacht. Es gibt eine Erweiterung, die heißt Trace Monkey, was ein Tracing Just-in-Time-Compiler gesponsert von Adobe ist, der auch in Flash drin ist.
Was heißt das? Tracing Just-in-Time-Compiler?
Ein Just-in-Time-Compiler wird ja in vielen dynamischen und interpretierten Programmesprachen benutzt, um sozusagen den Quellcode zur Laufzeit in Maschinencode zu übersetzen.
Bestes Beispiel, die Java.
Vor allem in Java und dort net wird das gemacht. Und das Problem ist, dass man das in dynamischen Programmesprachen nicht ohne Weiteres machen kann, weil man ja die Typen nicht kennt. Und deswegen auch kein Code erzeugen kann. Und ein Tracing-JIT löst das Problem, indem der einfach guckt so, okay, ich führe das Programm mal aus und habe so eine Vor-Loop-Mei wegen und da ist so eine i-Variable und die wird immer inkrementiert. Und das sieht ja aus wie ein Integer. Und dann kann man ja Code erzeugen, der einfach davon ausgeht, dass sich das auch nicht ändern wird, dass das einfach ein Integer ist. Und der macht das dann einfach und hat dann natürlich so einen gewissen Overhead, weil die Typ-Prüfungen müssen drin bleiben, um sozusagen diese optimistische Prognose, dass sich wohl nicht ändern wird, immer nochmal wieder zu validieren. Aber abgesehen von dieser einen Typ-Prüfung ist es sozusagen dann reiner Maschinencode.
Verstehe, das heißt, so eine Art Spion im Interpreter-Compiler-Gestrüpp, der immer schaut, ob denn irgendwo sich noch zur Laufzeit eine weitere Optimierung ergibt.
Genau, und der dann sozusagen diesen optimistischen Pfad so lange läuft, wie das geht, und sonst wieder in langsamer Ausführung zurückspringt, wenn man da irgendwas ändert.
Also es kann jetzt nicht sein, dass durch diese Optimierung das dann irgendwann mal bricht, sondern er hat dann immer wieder seinen Fallback, im schlimmsten Fall ist es dann wieder etwas langsamer, aber es ist nicht so, dass es nicht gehen würde.
Genau.
Und hat Trace Monkey gegenüber Spider Monkey dann erheblich was gebracht an Performance?
Also die arbeiten ja generell auch an der Engine und deswegen wird es sowieso die ganze Zeit schneller. Wenn Trace Monkey wirklich gut verwendet werden kann, also wenn ich meinen wegen einen Ray Tracer baue oder so, ist das einfach dramatisch viel schneller. Wenn ich so den aller Welts JavaScript Code baue, um irgendwie ein Layer ein- und auszumachen, dann ist es sowieso scheißegal, wie lange es dauert.
Ja, aber im Prinzip sind das schon so die Systematiken, die dann auch JavaScript komplett neue Anwendungsflächen eröffnen. Also es geht jetzt nicht nur so wirklich sozusagen um dieses eigentliche, was ja im Namen auch drinsteckt, so dieses Scripting einer Umgebung, sondern schon es scheint diesem Pfad zu geben, JavaScript auch für die generelle Applikationsentwicklung, außerhalb des Webs dieses Tor zu öffnen. Das ist zumindest mein Eindruck.
Auf jeden Fall wird halt im Augenblick unglaublich viel Geld investiert, um JavaScript schnell zu machen. Also keine andere Programmesprache kann da mithalten im Augenblick. Und sie ist halt auch schon sehr viel schneller. Also in so Benchmarks hat man, wenn man so die C-Implementierung für eins sieht, und dann kommt Java und C-Sharp von der Größenordnung immer so bei 2-, 3-, 4-mal so langsam raus. Und Perl, Python und Ruby, die ja eher von der Dynamik ähnlich JavaScript sind, sind ungefähr 40-mal bis 200-mal so langsam. Und JavaScript kommt da eher so bei Faktor 8 raus. Also es ist nur doppelt so langsam wie Java und auch nur 8-mal so langsam wie C, bei natürlich immer irgendwelchen Use-Cases, wo das halt so ist. Aber von der Größenordnung ist es halt wesentlich schneller als die anderen dynamischen Programmesprachen.
Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, gibt es ja jetzt auch schon bei den ersten Implementierungen richtig schon Bestrebungen, dann zur Laufzeit auch wirklich richtigen Code zu erzeugen. Also quasi diesen richtigen Compiler. Jetzt komme ich glaube ich selber ein bisschen in die Spuren. Es gab da irgendeine Optimierung. Wo war denn das? Ich glaube sowohl bei V8 als auch bei WebKit. Aber vielleicht kommen wir einfach mal darauf, bevor ich hier irgendwie etwas erzähle, was ich eh nicht weiß. Kurz noch mal zu dem Trace Monkey und Adobe. Also das, was sie da sozusagen reingeworfen haben, war eigentlich Arbeit, was sie an ihrem ActionScript gemacht haben. Also an der Stelle gab es sozusagen schon einen Austausch. Und man merkt auch, dass Adobe jetzt auch nicht vollständig abgekoppelt ist von der generellen JavaScript-Linie. Man hat ja immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass sie von ihrem Flash so recht nicht lassen wollen.
Also Adobe ist im Augenblick ein, glaube ich, schwieriges Thema, weil die nicht so in der richtigen Richtung haben. Also das war natürlich nett von ihnen, dass sie das gemacht haben mit Tamarin und TraceMonkey.
Also Tamarin war...
Tamarin heißt das Teil, was Adobe gebaut hat.
Ach so, und das wurde dann TraceMonkey genannt.
Sie haben, das ist ja mit Adobe gerade ein bisschen kontrovers, dass sie offenbar zumindest so aussehen, als würden sie versuchen, die Standardisierung von HTML5 zu verlangsamen. Und sie sind, glaube ich, im Augenblick ziemlich unter Druck, weil sie halt ihre Fälle wegschwimmen sehen. Würden sie also vermutlich jetzt nicht mehr spenden.
Was mich ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen verwundert, weil eigentlich weiß ich gar nicht, wovor sie so eine große Angst haben. Ich meine, wenn... Ich meine, in der Diskussion gerade derzeit steht natürlich Flash als Delivery-Format und es ist natürlich klar, dass wenn man irgendwie Herrscher über so ein System ist, dass man eine Menge Kontrolle hat. Aber es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass Adobe damit unmittelbar so viel Geld verdienen würde. Die Kernmarkts sind ja eigentlich auch andere Geschichten.
Genau, die Kernmarkts sind ja eigentlich der Verkauf von Authoring-Software.
Und das müsste ja eigentlich mit JavaScript genauso funktionieren.
Genau, sie könnten ja... Es gibt ja eine Implementierung von Flash 1, die schon in JavaScript läuft. Super beeindruckend. Und natürlich könnten sie auch irgendwann den Schritt gehen und sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt...
Ist das dieses Gordon, oder wie heißt das?
Ich weiß den Namen leider nicht.
Ja, ich habe von so einem System Gordon gehört, das irgendwie Flash in JavaScript macht.
Und daher... Also irgendwann können sie einfach ihre... Was ja eh ein anderes Thema ist noch, aber sagen einfach ihre... Statt zu Swift-Files einfach zu HTML-Seiten und JavaScript kompilieren aus Flash.
Wäre eigentlich alles gut. Na gut, wir wollen uns nicht so viel über Adobe unterhalten, aber das ist natürlich so ein interessanter Faktor, welche Rolle die jetzt spielen. Jetzt vielleicht nochmal zu den Implementierungen. Spider Monkey hatten wir jetzt genannt, bzw. in seiner zweiten Ausprägung dann halt Trace Monkey. Daran wird weiter gearbeitet. Mozilla hat eine ganze Menge Geschwindigkeitsverbesserungen erzielt. Ich kann jetzt diese Benchmarks auch nicht so runter beten, aber das war ja so in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren ganz extrem so. Aber eine große Rolle spielen ja auch Google und Apple. Was haben die gemacht?
Ja, einmal hat Apple ja mit Safari irgendwann entschieden, dass sie auch mal einen eigenen Browser bauen. Und dort im Grunde fast das Thema Geschwindigkeit losgetreten, dass das wieder ein großes Thema wird. Und haben ihre JavaScript-Implementierung mit dem Namen Squirrelfish in den Markt geworfen, die von vornherein darauf designt war, besonders schnell zu sein. Dann kam Google aufs Spielfeld mit Chrome und dem darin eingebauten Engine V8, die von den Jungs ist, der heißt Hot Iron, der ursprüngliche JIT in Java ist das, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Das ist so die Historie, wo die so herkommen.
Also sowohl Google als auch Apple scheinen sich wirklich aktiv Compiler-Species an Start gebracht zu haben, um einfach ihre JavaScript-Implementierung schnell zu machen. Wer hat also die Nase vorn?
Die Nase vorn hat V8, also Google, aber man kämpft halt...
Dicht an dicht. Unter einander nehmen die sich eigentlich nichts. Aber im Verhältnis zu den alten Implementierungen macht es einen riesen Unterschied.
Wesentlich schneller. Und es wird viel Geld investiert. So Sachen, die über Jahre lang konstant geblieben sind. Zum Beispiel, dass im Grunde jede Programmi-Sprache auf der Welt, außer Perl, nutzt ja diese Bibliothek PerlRI, Perl-Compatible Regular Expressions. Und das war auch in JavaScript drin. Und niemand spricht darüber, jetzt in Python oder Ruby eine neue Regular Expression-Engine zu bauen, weil das irgendwie immer okay war. Aber in V8 und in JavaScript Core sind halt JIT Compiler für Regular Expression drin, weil sie irgendwie da im Benchmark noch gesehen haben, da können wir irgendwie noch mal was machen. Und das zeigt halt, wie kreativ da gearbeitet wird, um die Sprache schneller zu machen.
Unterscheiden die beiden Implementierungen sich technisch groß? Oder ist das jetzt eigentlich nur dasselbe in grün?
Die unterscheiden sich schon. Wo ich jetzt ein bisschen zu doll ins Detail gehen würde, im Augenblick ist es so, dass sozusagen immer Apple im Lead ist und Features implementiert. Und V8 sozusagen ausschließlich nur Sachen baut, die auch in JavaScript Core sind. Also sie versuchen da extrem komfortabel zu sein. Sie sind aber sozusagen im technischen Detail beide halt auf der grünen Wiese angefangen und haben halt verschiedene Plattformen.
Was meinst du mit Apple ist mit WebKit in the Lead?
Nee, da geht es eher um Features. Die Mozilla-Leute sind immer relativ viel dabei, auch mal neue Sprachfeatures auszuprobieren. Und Apple ist dann viel konservativer und baut nur Sachen ein, die standardisiert wurden. Und V8 baut nur Sachen ein, die Apple eingebaut hat. Also das ist deren ganz klare Policy. Es gibt zum Beispiel ein Nicht-Standard-Feature, was super sinnvoll ist in Spider-Machie. Das ist Unterstrich-Unterstrich-No-Such-Method-Unterstrich-Unterstrich-Methode, die man definieren kann, die dann aufgerufen wird, wenn eine Methode nicht da ist. Irgendwie kommt das ursprünglich auf Smart-Talk, da war das Message noch unterstellt in Perl-Auto-Load. Oder in Ruby-Message-Mething. Das gibt es in den anderen Implementierungen nicht. Und immer wenn man einen Bug einstellt, hier könnt ihr ihn nicht mal, und jemand auch einen Patch, zum Beispiel bei V8, geliefert hat, um das Performant zu implementieren, wird dabei nicht aufgenommen, weil sie halt kompatibel sein wollen zu Apple.
Und warum nimmt Apple das nicht auf?
Weiß ich nicht genau.
Hält sich dann sozusagen Apple an diesen ECMA-Standard, und das ist sozusagen ihr hoher Lied?
Also das ist auf jeden Fall das, woraus sie sich zurückziehen. Wobei sozusagen natürlich gewisse De-Facto-Standards schon auch mal in die Sprache aufgedommen werden müssen, weil ja dieser ECMA-Prozess doch sehr, sehr, sehr langsam ist. Und im Wesentlichen nicht stattgefunden hat in den letzten acht Jahren oder sogar fast zehn Jahren. Also jetzt gerade ist ja ein neuer Standardverabschiedet worden. Und da ist sozusagen über Jahre hinweg überhaupt nichts passiert.
Jetzt gibt es auch noch Implementierungen von JavaScript in anderen Umgebungen. Du erwähntest im Vorgespräch Rhino.
Genau, das ist eine Implementierung in Java, die insofern wichtig ist, weil viele JavaScript-Server-Side-Implementierungen darauf fußen, weil man sozusagen dieses Problem, dass es irgendwie keine Standard-Bibliothek gibt, damit umschifft, dass man eigentlich alle Java-Objekte benutzen kann. Und wenn man so Sachen macht, wie wir eine Datei öffnen, was ja irgendwie in JavaScript nicht vorgesehen ist, geht das halt. Und das ist sozusagen deswegen da eine Implementierung, die relativ viel eingesetzt wird. Zum Beispiel kann man damit, wenn man Google App Engine nutzt, Server-side JavaScript nutzen, weil man da einfach Rhino dann in die Java-Implementierung rein...
Google App Engine ist was genau?
Das ist eine Cloud-Plattform von Google, um dort Anwendungen in deren Infrastruktur deployen zu können.
In welcher Form der Sprache?
Ursprünglich Python, mittlerweile auch Java. Und wenn man Rhino da reinwirft, dann auch Java.
Das heißt, Rhino ist eine Implementierung, mit der man im Prinzip sicherstellen kann, dass man Javascript-Code zum Laufen bekommt, auch wenn es nur Java-VM gibt. Andererseits kann man ja davon ausgehen, dass sich eine Java-VM heutzutage fast überall entfalten lässt, weil es einfach so weit verbreitet ist. Wie äußert sich das dann so performancemäßig?
Das ist miserabel. Es basiert einfach auf Code von vor zehn Jahren. Und da wurde auch nicht viel dran gemacht seitdem. Ein ganz klassischer Interpreter, der natürlich auch noch, weil er in Java geschrieben ist, langsamer ist als die C-Implementierung. Oft ist es ja wiederum nicht so wichtig. Gerade so in klassischer Web-Anwendung, Server-side-Code, da ist ja so reine Role-Performance selten ein Problem.
Inwieweit drängt denn JavaScript überhaupt auf die Server-Seite? Ich meine, beim Client ist es irgendwie der King. Das hat man ja eingangs schon festgestellt. Das ist ja auch schon lange klar. Was war verkannt, aber es ist da und was anderes ist da nicht. Aber auf der Server-Seite ist es ja nun genau das Gegenteil. Da ist ja eigentlich JavaScript nicht vorhanden.
Ja, es geht jetzt gerade los. Also ich habe gerade ein ungefähr 500-Person-Tage-Projekt gemacht auf Basis von Server-side JavaScript. Also es ist sozusagen auch richtig in der Enterprise-Welt angekommen. Aber davon abgesehen, ist sozusagen diese Bewegung gerade erst im Kommen. Also losgegangen ist es im Grunde im Januar letzten Jahres. Ich glaube Kevin Dangor hat eine Gruppe eröffnet bei Google Groups. Sie haben sie Server.js genannt und versucht angefangen, so Standard zu setzen, wie man Dateien öffnen könnte und Module und so weiter.
Was ist sein Hintergrund?
Wer ist er? Sein Hintergrund ist, dass er irgendwie Python gemacht hat und auf einmal JavaScript cool fand und bekannt für TurboGears, wenn man sich so ein bisschen in der Python-Welt auskennt.
Eins der beiden großen Web-Frameworks in der Python-Welt neben Django.
Genau. Und mittlerweile arbeitet er bei Mozilla im Bestbin-Projekt. Das ist ein browserbasierter Source-Code-Editor. Ein Open-Source-Projekt, in dem ich auch eine Weile gearbeitet habe. Habe ich aber letztes Jahr nicht mehr gemacht. Und da ist es losgegangen, ganz massiv. Und dann war die JSConf in Washington, wo Server-side JS praktisch nur noch so ein Track-B BarCamp, ein Vortragthema war. Und dann ist es explodiert und war auf der EU-Konferenz ein halbes Jahr später wirklich schon ein sehr großes Thema. Und jetzt, was der Ausschlag geben war, sicher war das Thema Node.js von Ryan Dahl, der damals noch in Deutschland gewohnt hat. Mittlerweile ist er gerade umgezogen, wieder zurück in die USA. Und der quasi so einen Vortrag gehalten hat auf der JS-Cont, wo es hinterher Standing Ovations gab und alle Leute im Raum Gänsehaut hatten. Und das ist halt irgendwie krasser Scheiß.
Warum? Was ist da so dran? Also was ist es? Also ist es ein Teil von V8 oder funktioniert nur damit?
Es ist eine Runtime für Server-side JavaScript, in der V8 genutzt wird, um das JavaScript auszuführen und wo sozusagen Kram rumgebaut ist. Und die Idee, die da drin ist und die es auch anders macht als alle anderen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen krass gesagt, aber in der Konsequenz ist es richtig. Es basiert halt vollständig auf nicht blockender IO., also eventgetriebener Programmierung. Und JavaScript eignet sich ja extrem dafür, weil es auch dafür designed war, weil so ist es ja im Browser, man hat irgendwie Events und Regierte drauf. Und Node.js ist sozusagen eine Abbildung von dessen auf die Serverseite. Das heißt, man in Node blockt nie etwas. Also man kann, wenn man was auf die Konsole schreibt, ist überhaupt kein Problem, aber man kriegt halt einen Callback, wenn es fertig ist. Die gesamte POSIX-API als Non-Blocking steht zur Verfügung. Ein High-Performance-Web-Server ist eingebaut. High-Performance-HTTP-Clienten, Non-Blocking-DNS-Resolver. Halt alle diese Sachen, die es gibt als Non-Blocking.
Das ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen der heilige Gral, den es derzeit so zu finden gibt. Alle sind irgendwie auf dir drauf gekommen, so oh holla, jetzt haben wir ganz viele Cores, ganz viele Cluster, alles muss sich irgendwie verteilen, nur unsere Software verteilt sich nicht, weil wir immer noch bei diesem Spaghetti-Konzept aus den 50er Jahren sind, dass da so eine CPU läuft und ein Programm nacheinander ausführt.
Genau, und Threads haben wir halt irgendwie nicht im Griff. Wir haben kein bekanntes Programmierkonzept, wo man mit Threads arbeitet und nicht alles kaputt geht. Und das ist sozusagen natürlich in eventgetriebener Programmierung einfacher. Also man muss sich daran auch gewöhnen. Viele Leute fangen damit an und bauen einen unglaublich komplizierten Quellcode, weil sie nicht aus dem Kopf kriegen, dass man in JavaScript keine Threads hat und deswegen Sachen bauen kann, die in Java zum Beispiel auf die Fresse fallen würden. Also man weiß halt, wenn ich eine Zeile habe und da was tue und dann in die nächste Zeile komme, dass da zwischendurch niemand was gemacht haben kann. Weil einmal ein Execution-Kontext, wenn er erst mal anfängt, so was auszuführen, dann macht er das, bis das vorbei ist und macht zwischendurch nie was anderes. Und sobald man natürlich Events da rein kriegt, dann kann man nie so genau, also dann kommen natürlich so Teile der Thread-Problematik wieder zurück, weil man mit Global State natürlich trotzdem aufpassen muss, weil die Events natürlich in chaotischer Reihenfolge feuern, aber zumindest weiß man, dass wenn man dann mal ran ist, dann kann einem niemand mehr dazwischen funken.
Bei Java?
Bei JavaScript.
Also man kriegt halt ein Event, man hat irgendwie einen ATP aufgemacht und kriegt einen Callback, dass es jetzt fertig ist, und kann dann das Ergebnis verarbeiten, ohne Angst haben zu missen, dass jemand anders einen jetzt voll in die Execution rein drückt und nochmal was anderes macht und den State halt zerstört.
Aber trotzdem, was wäre, wenn ich jetzt, mir kann keiner in die Quere kommen, was ist, wenn ich jetzt an der Stelle da meine Endlosschleife starte? Dann bin ich doch blocking oder was? Dann blockiere ich aber auch alles andere.
Dann bin ich halt kaputt.
Ja, aber dann meintest du doch vorhin irgendwie, ist ja doch alles so schön non-blocking.
Ja, genau, also alles außerhalb der JavaScript. Aber ich mache ja in einem typischen Programm, also so eine typische Web-Anwendung, Server-seitig. Die macht ja eigentlich nichts. Sie sagt irgendwie, hier Datenbank, guck mal nach und dann kommt was zurück. Und dann sagt sie, ja, hier Web-Service. Und kommt was zurück und malt das dann im Template. Das ist ja was eine Web-Anwendung üblicherweise tut. Und das heißt, eigentlich chillt sie die ganze Zeit und wartet darauf, dass irgendwie was kommt. Und in dieser Zeit macht eine Anwendung, die blocking ist, ja nichts. Und Node.js baut die ganze Zeit andere Requests durch. Also um mal ein Beispiel zu nennen.
Also du meinst, wenn jetzt sozusagen der Clique geht ins Java-Server-Backend und während dann das Java auf die Datenbank wartet, passiert nichts anderes.
Genau, der Thread ist halt gestalt und wartet.
Aber es könnte ja mehrere Threads geben.
Genau, dann hat man den Context Switch Overhead.
Das heißt, man muss sozusagen auf Betriebssystem oder VM-Ebene mit Threads arbeiten und bei JavaScript fällt das weg. Es gibt eigentlich nur ein Thread. Alles läuft innerhalb eines Prozesses oder eines Threads. Aber das JavaScript-Event-Modell selbst garantiert sozusagen für diese granulare Verteilung. Und das kann es dadurch sicherstellen, dass wenn jetzt, ich meine, ich muss ja dann sozusagen auch vom JavaScript auf die Datenbank, was immer das jetzt sein mag, irgendwie was erfragen.
Genau, da ist es halt immer so, dass man niemals, man schreibt halt nicht Result Set gleich Query, sondern man schreibt Query und gibt dann einen Callback, der aufgerufen wird, sobald das Ergebnis da ist. Und in der Zwischenzeit können andere Anfragen beantwortet werden.
Das heißt auch die Antwort ist sozusagen ein Event.
Um mal ein Beispiel zu nennen, ich habe letzten Sommer das Gefühl gehabt, dass das Internet kaputt geht, weil alle immer nur URL-Shorten benutzen. Und habe deswegen ein Projekt gestartet.
Also sowas wie Bit.ly, Tai-URL und so weiter.
Und das wurde dann auch kurz später als dann Trim-Plydaging bestätigt. Und habe deswegen in Node.js einen Client für die Twitter-Streaming-RP geschrieben, der die gesamten Twitter-Streams bekommt. Also ich habe nur Access bekommen für 15%, aber das ist auch schon eine ganze Menge. Und dieser Node.js Client empfängt sozusagen diesen Stream.
Also Stream von allen Tweets, die bei Twitter so rausfallen.
Und löst die Kurz-ULs auf und speichert beides in der Datenbank. Und dann gibt es einen Plugin für einen Browser, wo der die Auflösung über diese Datenbank vornimmt und sozusagen auch Links auflösen kann, wenn der, wenn Bit.ly halt gerade nicht antwortet.
Ah, verstehe. Man baut sich jetzt also für so Extensions, was weiß ich jetzt, im Firefox oder im Chrome, also die Browser, die sowas zulassen. So nach dem Motto, hier ist eine Bit.ly-URL, dann kennt er die, weiß, aha, das ist so ein URL-Shortener und wenn der dann irgendwie nicht reagiert, weil, keine Ahnung, verkauft, Server down oder auch gerade mal kein Internet, dann geht er alternativ auf deine Datenbank und holt sich das sozusagen aus dem ewigen Archiv.
Darum geht es ja eigentlich gar nicht, sondern das geht eigentlich darum, dass diese Implementierung, genau, diese Node.js-Implementierung lief halt auf meinem Mac Mini und hat genau 0% CPU verbraucht, um den Twitter-Stream zu empfangen und alles Short-URLs aufzulösen in Echtzeit.
Wie viele URLs waren das pro Sekunde?
Viele, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Größenordnung? 10, 100, 1000?
Ja, so 500.
500 Resolvings. Und du sagst, im Wesentlichen hat das Ding halt einfach im Hintergrund DNS-Dispatched. Also das heißt, es lief auf dein Mac Mini und der Mac OS X innerhalb von Node.js als JavaScript-Anwendung und hat dabei die Non-Blocking-DNS-Resolver-Routinen von Node.js, die Node.js bereitstellt, verwendet?
Also den Non-Blocking hat der PClient halt vor allem. Ja, die Anwendung selbst tut ja eigentlich nicht viel. Also 500 Sachen auf einem Rechner in einer Sekunde zu machen, ist ja erstmal nicht viel. Aber 500 Requests zu machen in einer Blocking-Implementierung mit 500 Threads, das in Java zu bauen, da braucht man halt einen Moment, bis das performt. Und das ist halt in Node.js einfach ein Selbstgänger. Also man muss halt bei Node.js immer eher aufpassen, dass man nicht komplette Dynal-of-Service-Attacken startet.
Weil die analogisch mithalten können.
Bei default macht man halt immer so viele Requests wie gehen. Also die Grenze ist relativ weit oben.
Wie fertig ist dieses Node.js?
Also das ist super stabil und fertig. Es ist allerdings so, dass Ryan extrem bereit ist, wenn er irgendwas Scheiße findet, das auch wieder anders zu machen. Okay, moving target. Die API ändert sich sehr stark. Das kann natürlich auch mal ein bisschen frustrierend sein, dass das Programm von vor einer Woche halt nicht mehr geht. Aber er will es halt irgendwie richtig machen. Richtig, da bin ich halt irgendwie ideal und hat auch gesagt, dass er demnächst sozusagen einmal einen Release macht, was dann auch so sein wird, wie es sein soll, aber im Augenblick noch sehr liberal geändert.
Also es läuft, aber es ist Alpha-Version, weil es halt einfach noch nicht gefixt ist in der Art und Weise, wie es intern wirklich funktioniert.
Ja, sozusagen die API ist halt nicht fixiert.
Ja, deswegen sage ich Alpha. Ich weiß ja, heutzutage werden die Begriffe ja ganz anders benutzt, als ich es mal früher etabliert habe, aber als ich jung war, da war eine Alpha-Version.
Aber Alpha-Versionen müssen so klingen, als wäre das Ding nicht stabil. Das ist es halt.
Es ist eine stabile Alpha.
Es stürzt halt nicht ab, aber niemand garantiert, dass das Programm mit der Version in einer Woche noch geht.
Verstehe. Also ist das das einzige Environment, was sowas tut? Also das ist jetzt das, was V8 verwendet. Gibt es auch noch andere Server-side Umgebungen?
Es gibt aus der Server-JS-Group, die sich dann irgendwann in CommonJS umwandeln hat. Aus diesem Umfeld gibt es einen Standard und eine Implementierung namens Narwhill sowie der Wal mit dem Horn.
Narwhal.
Narwhal. Und dafür gibt es relativ viele Implementierungen. Die am weitesten fortgeschrittene ist, glaube ich, ist eine auf Rhino-Basis. Es gibt auch eine V8-Implementierung, eine Spider-Market-Implementierung und jeweils auch noch fünf andere, die in einem verschiedenen State sind, in einem Reifegrad. Das ist aber sozusagen, zumindest in der ursprünglichen Design, mehr so klassisch designt. Sprich, ja, halt Blocking und...
Jetzt kommen wir zum interessanten Punkt. Bisher war es ja so, JavaScript hat eigentlich im Wesentlichen im Webclient fungiert und wir haben es ja schon erwähnt, dass das Modell der Wahrnehmung der Außenwelt, also für so ein Stück JavaScript-Code, was ja dann auch noch in der Regel, also am Anfang im HTML war, also so direkt an Elemente dran gemacht, wenn auf dieses Objekt draufgeklickt wird, dann konsumiere doch bitte diesen Event in Form dieses kurzen JavaScript-Snippets. Das sind diese typischen An-Aus-Click-Aufklapp-Systeme der einfachen Art. Bis hin zu heute, wo dann schon komplett im Header vollständige JavaScript-Sourcecode-Dateien mit eingebaut werden. So wie man auch Style-Sheets lädt, lädt man halt auch JavaScript-Dokumente. Das ist sozusagen schon so richtig vollständiger Code, wie man das eben aus anderen Programmiersprachen kennt, der sich jetzt nicht mit HTML mischt. Trotz alledem, die Welt, die dieser Code sieht, ist das Fenster, ist der Browser bzw. das Dokument, was in dem Moment gerade geladen ist, was der aktuelle Kontext ist. Und eigentlich ist das Ganze nur so eine Hierarchie, wo man dann halt irgendwie rumschrauben kann. Man kann Elemente hinzufügen, man kann Elemente entfernen, umbenennen, editieren, was auch immer. Aber man kann dann nicht im Dateisystem schreiben und man kann überhaupt nicht wirklich so Dinge tun, die man jetzt sozusagen von so einem richtigen Programm, so einer richtigen Desktop-Anwendung gewohnt ist. Das ist ja auch richtig so, das hat ja auch Sicherheitsgründe und das ist ja nun auch so das Ding. Nur die Komplexität des diesen JavaScript umgebenden Systems war und ist ja nicht sehr hoch. Also ich meine, auch in diesem DOM-Modell hat sich so über die Zeit ein bisschen was getan und da gab es dann mehr Standardisierung, mehr Features. Aber im Prinzip ist das ja eine endliche Geschichte. Wie sieht das dann auf der Server-Seite aus? Ist das dann so genauso karg? Da braucht man ja dann auch ganz andere Dienstleistungen, um das wirklich zum Laufen zu bekommen. Dateizugriff hast du ja schon erwähnt und sowas.
Also so viel braucht man ja gar nicht heutzutage. Also mit HTTP kommt man ja mittlerweile relativ weit. Also Datenbanken wie CouchDB fangen an, von klassischen Native-C-Interfaces hinzugehen zu einem REST-Modell, wo man HTTP mit denen spricht. Und deswegen mit Node, wo eine API-Dokumentation ist, die man so in einer halben Stunde durchlesen kann, kann man praktisch jedes Programm heutzutage mitbauen. Und da ist halt nicht viel dran. Aber sicher wird da nach und nach Infrastruktur gebaut werden müssen. Also zum Beispiel eine AMQP-Implementierung für Queueing. Und wenn man mit einer klassischen Datenbank sprechen will, dann mal einen Treiber für, sowas gibt es natürlich alles noch nicht. Das ist gerade erst im Aufbau.
AMQP, erwähnen das ja auch eine relativ neue Geschichte, wenn ich es richtig sehe. Was heißt das nochmal? Advanced Message Queueing-Protokoll. Kommt glaube ich auch aus der Python-Welt.
Ne, es kommt aus der Telekom-Welt, weil die ja solche Probleme, solche Systeme halt brauchen.
Ich rieche Erlang. Hat das was damit zu tun?
Also die, ähm...
Ach so, der Server ist dann in Erlang geschrieben?
Ja, eine der Implementierungen ist Revit-MQ. Und das ist eine Erlang-Implementierung.
Ah, okay.
Von unserem Message String-Broker, ja. Aber das ist ja auch ein, gerade auch wenn man Non-Blocking baut auf der Applikationsebene, ist natürlich so ein Message-Q-Teil, will man halt immer haben. Also ich sage heutzutage, man kann eigentlich kein Projekt mehr machen. Früher hat man gesagt, ich brauche irgendwie Mais-QL, jetzt brauchen wir eher eine Message-Q. Weil wenn so ein Web-Request kommt, dann hat man ja keinen Bock, den gleich zu bearbeiten. Das dauert ja viel zu lange manchmal.
Das heißt, man tut ja erstmal in irgendeine Q rein, und dann gibt es anderen Code, der quasi auf den Event reagiert, dass da ein neues Element in der Q gelandet ist? Kann man sich das so vorstellen?
Ja, sowas, dass man halt irgendwie kriegt einen Request und dann tut man das irgendwie schnell mal in den Caching-Layer, dass es schon so aussieht, als hätte man das bearbeitet. Und für die richtige Persistierung lässt man sich dann halt mehr Zeit, einfach um die Schnelligkeit niemals beeinträchtigen zu müssen, oder wenigstens von der Load.
Jetzt sind aber in letzter Zeit vor allem Programmiersprachen dadurch besonders bekannt geworden, dass sie ganz interessante Antworten auf die Frage gegeben haben, wie realisiere ich eine Web-Anwendung. Vor allem ist da, denke ich mal, Robi zu nennen, was ja sich eigentlich mit Rails überhaupt erst so richtig aus der Taufe gehoben hat. Also die Sprache ist nicht ursprünglich dafür geschrieben worden, aber erst nachdem es Rails gab, setzte er einen ganz unfassbaren Hype ein, der ja auch Früchte trägt. Und ich denke, dass die Robi- und Rails-Welt nachhaltig dazu beigetragen hat, Webseiten schöner und besser bedienbar zu machen. Trotz alledem gibt es ja dann auch immer wieder diese Überlappung mit JavaScript, weil in dem Moment, wo man irgendwie intelligenter in der Webseite agieren will, kommt man ja quasi um JavaScript nicht drum herum. Aber bevor wir vielleicht darauf nochmal eingehen, gibt es denn auch so Ansätze, so etwas wie Rails, solche Frameworks, die einem sozusagen das Erstellen von Web-Anwendungen vereinfachen sollen, auch in dieser JavaScript-Server-Site-Welt zu bringen?
Also ja, natürlich. Ich fand Rails immer in gewisser Weise langweilig, weil so Flood-Controller-getriebene Web-Entwicklungen haben wir halt schon alle lange gemacht. Es war im Grunde keine Revolution, wenn man sich in der Szene auskannte, aber sie haben es schon richtig gemacht und waren auch cool, dass sie gesagt haben, wir haben irgendwie eine Meinung, wir machen das halt so. Aber insofern hat es die Art, wie man Anwendungen baut, im Grunde nicht revolutioniert. Und sozusagen dieses Versprechen, dass wir alle schön reich werden und viel mehr Zeit für Sex haben und so. Das kommt ja alle paar Jahre mal. Das ändert aber nichts daran, dass die Software trotzdem buggy ist. Und Performance bottlenecks hat. Was ich an Node insbesondere so spannend finde, ist, dass das wirklich anders funktioniert. Die Programmierung ist nicht so, wie wir das die letzten zehn Jahre gemacht haben. Gerade, wenn man in Richtung Comet schaut, das ist der neue Begriff für Server Push.
Das heißt doch wieder irgendwas Schnuckeliges, oder? So schön leuchtet.
Das passt zum Thema Realtime-Web. Klassisch haben wir so HTTP-Request-Response-Cycle. Die Seite aktiviert sich wesentlich nur, wenn ich auf Reload drücke. Ich hab so langweilige Polling-Geschichten, wo ich alle 10 Sekunden nachfrag, ob sich was geändert hat. Mit Comet ist es eventgetrieben, wo der Server dem kleinen Bescheid sagt, wenn er weiß, dass sich was geändert hat. Was viel effizienter ist und viel schneller. Dafür brauche ich eine Server-Implementierung, die überhaupt eine Lage ist, allen Besuchern eine Verbindung auf uns zu halten. Das kann ich mit Rails nicht bauen, weil es überhaupt nicht dafür designt ist. Das geht mit solchen Technologien viel besser. Es gibt auch die Ruby-Implementierung, die das versucht, das Event-Maschinen, Twisted für Python, die auch in diese Richtung gehen. Die aber nicht so radikal sind. Wenn ich Event-Maschinen benutze, und ich habe aber keinen Non-Blocking-Datenbankzugriff, dann habe ich natürlich schnell diese Probleme, dass meine Maschine nicht mehr reagieren kann, weil ich gerade irgendwie arbeite. Das ist in dieser Radikalität revolutionär in Note.
Aber vielleicht trotzdem... Talking about revolution... Ich denke, der Punkt, wo JavaScript für einen Großteil, was auch immer, wo es für viele Leute auf einmal wieder komplett neu auf der Liste stand, obwohl es da irgendwie schon immer hätte hingehört, meiner Meinung nach war die Geburt des Begriffes AJAX. Steht für asynchronous JavaScript und XML. Das war der erste Begriff, der da mal aufgeworfen wurde.
Tut es aber nicht mehr, nur wenn man das in Großbuchstaben schreibt, was man nicht mehr machen sollte.
Aha, sondern?
Ja, mit kleinen J, A und X.
Ah, verstehe.
Dann heißt es nicht mehr.
Das Ganze hat ja im Prinzip eine längere Geschichte. Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, ging das mal mit Microsoft los.
Genau, die haben sich XML-HTDP-Request ausgedacht.
Also eine Methode in ihrer JavaScript-Implementierung.
Genau, was eine API ist, um halt P-Request zu machen. Und deswegen ist es halt irgendwie blöd benannt, weil es ist erstmal ein HTTP-Request-API, wo man hinterher, wenn man XML bekommt, auf ein DUM-Model von diesem XML zugreifen kann. Das macht aber halt niemand. Provokativ gesagt, also natürlich gibt es Leute, die damit XML abrufen, das ist aber sehr selten. In der Regel nutzt man das halt als HTTP-Client, um HTML zu holen.
Das eigentlich war es ein HTTP-Request, der bloß dafür gedacht war, im Wesentlichen erstmal XML zu holen.
Genau, das war irgendwie deren Vision halt, wie man so Ende der 90er so dachte.
Aber schon der Aufruf selbst hat eigentlich nicht XML vorausgesetzt. So wie man ihn benutzt hat, hätte es auch irgendwas liefern können.
Nee, es ist auch so. Es gibt eine extra API, um aus dem Resultat XML rauszuholen. Aber erstmal hat man einfach einen Datenhaufen.
Okay, das heißt, man hätte es eigentlich Http-Request nennen können.
Das wäre halt besser gewesen.
Okay, naja, gut, aber da wissen wir ja nicht, ob Microsoft ist da immer ein bisschen wackelig.
Genau. Das gibt es schon sehr lange und Sachen werden ja immer nicht entdeckt und schlummern und irgendwann hat...
Das war ja eigentlich mal, ich meine, es ist ja selten, dass man mal Microsoft was Visionäres unterstellen kann, aber da waren sie ja schon weit voraus und sie haben ja auch damals, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, schon auch diesen Begriff Dynamic HTML geprägt, von dem damals eigentlich so noch keiner geredet hat oder eigentlich auch nicht so richtig zu träumen wagte. Die Leute waren auch so damit beschäftigt, überhaupt HTML als solches zu begreifen, dass wahrscheinlich diesen Schritt noch so gar nicht mitgehen konnten, schon gar nicht die Programmierer in Anbetracht der ganzen wackeligen Implementierungen und langsam Betriebssysteme. Aber das war eigentlich das erste Mal, wo der JavaScript-Welt die Möglichkeit gegeben war, eigenständig mit dem Server zu kommunizieren.
Genau. Und im Grunde war ja mal, kann man sich kaum dran erinnern, bei Internet Explorer 6 war ja mal der beste Browser im Markt. Also das ist wesentlich besser als Netzge4. Ich bin auch immer noch der Meinung, dass das Boxmodel vom IE6 eigentlich das Richtige ist. Aber die Welt hat sich ja anders entschieden. Man muss sich ja einigen, wenn man die Breite von einem Objekt misst, ob der Rahmen und der innere Rand und der äußere Rand mit zu breiter gehören oder nicht. Da gibt es halt unterschiedliche Meinungen zu. Der Standard ist halt anders als Wie ist der Standard bei IE6? Schwierige Frage. Im IE6 ist es so, dass die Breite halt die Breite ist. Im Standard ist der innere Rahmen und der Rand nicht Teil der Breite. Das heißt, die Breite muss man halt immer ausrechnen. Da muss man sie einfach einigen, wie man es will.
Okay, aber man kriegt es auf jeden Fall raus. Das ist bloß ein anderer Weg.
Also da gab es halt dieses Teil. Das haben natürlich hier und da mal Leute, ich glaube SAP, auch ganz weit vorne mit so einer Web-Gui und so, die das alle hatten. Aber so richtig ging es halt erst los mit AJAX. Und da ist halt wiederum ganz wichtig Prototype.js, was eine JavaScript-Bibliothek ist. Nicht die erste auf der Welt, aber eine der ersten, die halt auch mit Rails sozusagen durchgestartet ist. Und was die halt, was man denen wirklich zu gut halten muss, ist, was sie gemacht haben, sie haben halt diese völlig kaputte API des Document Object Models halt heil gemacht. Und das hat sozusagen, denke ich, zur Explosion von JavaScript in der Nutzung geführt, weil dieses Gefühl, vorher war ja, ich habe irgendwie so ein Moving Target und ich kann mich auf nichts verlassen und es tut halt voll weh damit zu programmieren, weil ich die ganze Zeit immer nur Sachen debacken muss.
Was war denn das Problem? Das verstehe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz genau. Also, hatten wir ja schon das Document Object Model, das war dann bei den Browser unterschiedlich.
Genau. Wie unterschiedlich? So unterschiedlich, dass man im Wesentlichen bei praktisch jedem Property Access gucken muss, ob das Ding da ist. halt nach mehreren gucken muss.
Das heißt, wenn man die Farbe von irgendwas ändern will?
Geht das halt irgendwie anders? Dass auch manchmal andere Werte erwartet werden und zurückgeliefert werden. Das war völlig im Arsch. Da kann man nicht gegen programmieren, ernsthaft.
Haben ja auch alle gestöhnt. Und haben ja auch alle so gestöhnt, dass es dann unter anderem ja auch noch zu dieser zur Gründung von diesem Verband der Web-Developer kam. Ich grubbe jetzt gerade, wie das hieß, das ist mit der Biene. Bies. Wie hieß denn das noch gleich?
Was meinst du?
Ich hatte das mal hier bei dem Usability. Hat mal ein CRE. Jetzt muss ich glaube mal nachdenken. Ich glaube, es war nicht 102. ich hab's gleich. Moment. Gut, dass wir das Internet haben. Über Barrierefreiheit im Web gesprochen. Das Web-Standardsprojekt. Das hat sich ja mal so aus diesem Widerstand der Web-Developer gegründet, die irgendwann keinen Bock mehr hatten, sich von den Browser-Herstellern an der Nase herumzuführen. Da ging's jetzt nicht primär um JavaScript. Es war Teil der ganzen Geschichte. Es ging halt auch um diese ganzen wackeligen HTML-Standards, die ja auch nicht so richtig vorankamen. Das Web-Standardprojekt ist das mit dem Biene-Enterpo.
Ich glaube halt, dass der Gedanke in der API darauf zu basteln, die das sozusagen in eine unifizierte Sicht auf verschiedene Implementierungen in den Browsern gibt, das ist jetzt ja das war zwar revolutionär, aber es ist ja im Grunde auch nicht ungewöhnlich.
Also das ist das, was prototype.js gemacht hat.
Genau.
Wir reden von einem Framework, was man einfach per, wie nutzt man das, per Include oder was?
Man bindet es halt ein.
Von dem Original-Server oder hat man dann so seine eigene Kopie wahrscheinlich noch vorgehalten.
Und hinterher hat man eine API mit einer Dokumentation, die in allen Browsern sich völlig identisch verhält.
Das heißt, dieses Framework hat im Wesentlichen erstmal die Unterschiede der Browser encapsulated, sozusagen. Da hat man eine Schutzschicht drüber gesprüht und ein einheitliches Bedienwerkzeug ausgegeben.
Wir haben seit Prototype.js viel gelernt, wie man sowas tun sollte. Prototype hat verschiedene Design-Fehler, die man auch nicht reparieren kann. die man auch mal machen musste, um festzustellen, dass das irgendwie nicht so eine gute Idee ist. Also was mit deren Ansatz war erstmal die Apis heil zu machen. Aber sie eventuell, wenn es auch geht, nicht unbedingt zu verändern. Also sozusagen Properties hinzuzufügen, die fehlen zum Beispiel sowas. Und die heißen Prototype, weil sie prototypische Eigenschaft von JavaScript nutzen, native Objekte zu erweitern mit so Convenience-Methoden. Also zum Beispiel ForEach an einem Array, um da irgendwie drüber zu iterieren. Problem ist, dass JavaScript vor allem so, wie es auch immer noch ist und vor zehn Jahren war, leider nicht genug Tool zur Verfügung stellt, um wirklich gut die Standardtypen zu erweitern. Sodass man das auch nicht tun sollte. dadurch Prototype zu fiesen, kaum zu finden, in Bugs führt. Weil gewisse Annahmen über die Sprache nicht mehr gültig sind.
Verstehe. Das heißt, Sie haben versucht, sich das Leben dadurch einfacher zu machen, indem Sie auch noch neue Sprachelemente hinzufügen und sind dabei von gegebenen Vorausgegangen, die sich jetzt mit der Zeit geändert haben oder ändern werden?
Also, sie... Ja, es ist ein Detail in JavaScript, dass man kann halt über Objekte iterieren, über deren Keys. Und da bei dieser Iteration sind die Standardmethoden komm da nicht mit.
Ich glaube, vielleicht sollten wir das einfach mal an der Stelle anders aufdröseln und mal kurz wirklich auf die Sprache selbst zu sprechen kommen, weil ich glaube, bei diesen ganzen Frameworks spielen solche Maßgaben dann auch eine große Rolle. Wir haben jetzt viel darüber gesprochen, wir sind jetzt durch die Geschichte durchmarschiert, wir haben jetzt die ganzen Implementierungen und was sich daraus gemacht wird und auch schon weitgehend sozusagen die neuen Programmiermodelle, die sich daraus ergeben. Also einerseits natürlich die Rich-Klines, das geht dann immer weiter, aber eben auch diese Servergeschichte und überhaupt generell eine andere eventbasierte Kommunikation, die, sagen wir mal, den Anforderungen von heute, Skalierung, große Webseiten, Cluster, Parallelisierung, Multiple-Courses und so weiter entgegenkommen. Aber was ist denn wirklich in der Sprache? Also bleiben wir jetzt einfach mal wirklich nur bei der Programmiersprache als solchen, unabhängig von den Schnittstellen nach außen.
Wie...
Was ist das? Wie muss man sich JavaScript vorstellen?
Also der wirklich ganz große Unterschied zu den anderen Mainstream-Programmiersprachen ist, dass das Objektmodell anders funktioniert als ein anderen Objekt der orientierten Programmiersprachen. Das ist nämlich nicht klassenbasiert, sondern prototypbasiert, nennt man das. Und das basiert auf dem Gedanken, dass ich eigentlich Objekte habe und die haben Properties. Und wenn ich neues Objekt bauen will, dann basiere ich das einfach immer auf irgendeinem anderen Objekt, was schon da ist. Und dann füge an diese Kopie was hinzu, um das zu spezialisieren.
Also, während das klassische Klassenmodell von vorne rein immer, was in dem Namen drin steht, eine abstrakte Definition von etwas führt und dann baut man sich da ein Vererbungsmuster in dem Moment, wo man wirklich eine Instanz benötigt, also ein reales Objekt, in das ich auch Werte hineinspeichern kann und Attribute verändern kann. Dann beziehe ich mich auf dieses abstrakte Klassenmodell und sage, ich hätte jetzt ganz gern ein Objekt von diesem Typ und das Klassenmodell definiert, wie es ausgestattet ist und ein Stück weit auch, wie es sich verhält. Und genau dieses komplexe abstrakte Modell gibt es bei JavaScript nicht.
Genau.
Sondern jedes Objekt ist für sich selbst verantwortlich.
Jedes Objekt eine eigene Klasse, die auch einzeln verändert werden kann. Und Änderungen in einem Objekt haben keinerlei Auswirkungen auf irgendein anderes Objekt im System.
Aber jetzt möchte man ja schon in seinem Programm auch mal häufiger mehrere Objekte haben, die sich eigentlich alle gleich verhalten. Genau.
Das, was ich in JavaScript tue, ich instanziere Funktionen. Und das sind dann Objekte. Und diese Funktionen haben ein Property namens Prototype. Und alle Properties von diesem Prototype-Property werden Properties der Instanz der Funktion.
Das heißt, was ist denn sozusagen der Urschleim? Also, ich meine, wenn so ein JavaScript-Environment irgendwie jetzt hochkommt, was baut sich denn da überhaupt erstmal zusammen? Also, ich meine, ich habe jetzt so mein Execution-Environment, was weiß ich. Dieses V8, das wird irgendwie gestartet. Was ist am Anfang? Gibt es da überhaupt schon Objekte? Wo kommen die her? Wie bauen die sich? Wer erbt von wem?
Also, es gibt eine gewisse Standardumgebung, die immer da ist. Also, es gibt irgendwie Arrays. Es gibt Objects und Functions. grundsätzlich, also wenn man ganz, also ein normales JavaScript, wenn ich einen V8 anmache, dann ist da sonst auch gar nichts.
Es gibt Objekte, Funktionen und Arrays. Arrays sozusagen jetzt als eine Sonderform, die man einfach häufig benötigt, um mehrere Objekte in einer Reihe gut zu verhandeln.
Die unterscheiden sich von Objekten. Im Wesentlichen dadurch, dass es ein eigenes Literal dafür gibt, um die zu bauen. So eckige Klammern.
Also die Sprache hat davon sozusagen schon eine konkrete Vorstellung.
Die sind halt drin. Ja und die konkreten Implementierungen implementieren das halt auch als Array und tun. Man kann natürlich sich auch vorstellen, als ein Objekt, was irgendwie als Properties halt 1, 2, 3, 4 und so weiter hat.
Aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwie...
Kann man auch so behandeln. Also die Sprache nimmt einem das nicht übel, wenn man so tut, als ist ein Array ein Objekt.
Aber wenn ich jetzt irgendwie eine Variable, also wenn ich jetzt ein neues Objekt erstellen will, dann ist das doch jetzt auch erstmal nicht mehr als A gleich 5, oder? Oder muss ich da jetzt jedes Mal so eine Funktion aufrufen?
Nee, wenn ich A gleich 5 schreib, dann habe ich halt, also es gibt auch Literale für Integers und für Strings.
Das heißt, da wird eine Funktion aufgerufen, ich schreib das bloß nicht so hin.
Genau.
Und welche Funktion ist das?
Das ist ja ein sehr Implementierungsdetail. Also eine normale Implementierung würde vermutlich, wenn ich eine Zahl hinschreib, dann ist das auch erstmal so einem Special Case, wie es in vielen Programmi-Sprachen gibt, für Integers und für Floats und so, das ist was anderes, also es gibt auch eine Clusternummer, deren Instanzen, und die, wenn ich eine Zahl hinschreibe, dann ist die aber nicht Instanz dieser Clusternummer. Klasse ja natürlich auch immer nur im Anführungsstrichen.
Die hat jetzt aber keiner gesehen, die Anführungsstriche. Ich auch nicht.
Und da gibt es halt Autoboxing, wie in vielen modernen Programmersprachen, so dass dieser Unterschied zwischen den Native Types und diesen Klassen meistens egal ist.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe es noch nicht so ganz verstanden.
Aber das heißt zu sagen, mit dieser Podcast, da würde ich Strings und Zahlen und Errors erstmal, um das zu verstehen, weglassen, weil es abfalls nur Special Cases sind. Normalerweise kann ich Functions schreiben in JavaScript. Es ist im Kern sowieso eine funktionale Programmesprache. Insofern ist Lisp sehr viel näher, als es sehr nahe ist. Funktionen haben einen hohen Stellenwert, die kann ich sowohl als Funktion hinschreiben, die dann sozusagen ihren Namen in den nächsten lexikalen Scope reintut. Oder ich kann Funktionen in einem Dort hinschreiben, wo man in programmingsprachigen Expressions hinschreibt.
Funktionen sind sozusagen selber vollwertige Objekte, First Class Objects, wie man so schön sagt, die man genauso zuweisen kann wie alle anderen Zahlen und Werte und Objekte auch. Das heißt, man kann sie auch als Parameter übergeben, etc. Und dann ist das im Prinzip alles das Gleiche. Ich kann in der Variable sozusagen genauso eine Zahl haben wie eine Funktion. Das ist das, was du sagen willst.
Und dann kann ich halt auch diesen Funktionen, die kann ich mit U instanzieren. Und was dann passiert, ist, dass erstmal diese Funktion ausgeführt wird und der Return Value von diesem Statement ist halt ein Object.
Das heißt, diese Funktion repräsentiert sozusagen den Typ Objekt, den man haben will.
Genau.
Das heißt, diese Funktion selber ist sozusagen der Typ.
Und die kann, auch wenn sie ausgeführt wird, dann hat sie ein This und das ist das Objekt, was hinterher sozusagen von einem U returned wird. Und da kann man halt schon Properties rein tun. Und ja, im Grunde braucht man auch nicht mehr in der Programmesprache. Jetzt hat, wenn man rein so programmiert, dass immer wenn man Functions ausführt, da Properties reinbaut, hat das einen großen Nachteil. Nämlich, dass es unglaublich viel RAM braucht. Weil im Grunde jede jede, die seine eigene Beschreibung braucht. Genau. Immer wieder die gleichen Functions da rein geschrieben werden. Und das ist so viel, dass es wirklich auch ein Problem wäre, wenn das das einzige Verfahren wäre. Und deswegen gibt es halt dieses Prototype-Property, wo man Objekte definieren kann, wo man sozusagen von Objekten definieren kann, die von allen Instanzen von so einer Funktion dann geshared werden.
Das heißt, ich fasse mal zu, also diese Funktion haben die jetzt noch, sagt man immer Functions, sagt man Methods, vorhin hat du glaube ich Methods gesagt, Methods, Functions, ist das selbe.
Methods ist nicht das gleiche.
Ist nicht das gleiche. Okay, dann lassen wir es erstmal noch mal aus und vor. Also bleiben wir bei Funktionen. Diese Funktion, also nicht jede Funktion hat das, aber eine Funktion kann die Fähigkeit haben, ein Objekt zu erzeugen. Richtig? Und wenn es das tut, dann erzeugt es halt einerseits dieses Objekt, das heißt es schafft erstmal diesen Speicherraum. Das wird dann wahrscheinlich implizit schon durch diesen Aufruf des Operators New quasi auf JavaScript-Ebene vorausgesetzt. Dann weiß diese Funktion schon, dass sie sozusagen jetzt einen Sys hat und dass sie es alle reinpacken kann. Das heißt, in Abhängigkeit wahrscheinlich auch der Parameter, den man dieser Funktion übergibt, stopft es also nun dieses neue Objekt mit Inhalt voll, vererbt aber auch Property-Schema, sozusagen, was da so normalerweise drin ist, aus sich selbst da rein. Also die Funktion selber hat quasi schon diese Properties und jedes Objekt, was von dieser Funktion erzeugt wird, übernimmt die. Und in dem Objekt selbst steht dann keine vollständige Beschreibung mehr, welche Properties es gibt, sondern es steht sozusagen nur ein Ich-bin-ein-Kind von dieser Funktion und schau doch bitte da nach.
Genau, so kann man das zusammenfassen. Und das geht natürlich auch über N-Ebenen, um sozusagen einen Baum aufzubauen. Das ist dann die Prototype Inheritance Chain.
Das heißt, ich kann auch ein Wie läuft das dann? Dann muss das Objekt, was davon erzeugt wird, auch wieder eine Funktion sein? Oder wie beziehe ich mich dann sozusagen auf die Hierarchie?
Objekt, was da drin ist, hat ja dessen Properties werden vererbt. Das kann ja aber auch wieder Properties erben, von woanders. Aber das ist auch egal. Die Hierarchie ist halt eigentlich flach, weil das ja schon composed wurde, in dem Moment, wo ich das bei mir als Prototyp setze.
Das heißt, diese Vererbung ist eher eine Optimierung des Environments, die ich gar nicht sehe und die ich auch so nicht benutze?
Ich muss sie ja schon explizit verwenden. Weil ich muss ja diese Prototyperweiterung nutzen, um diese Optimierung zusammen genießen zu können.
Gibt da mal ein Beispiel für so ein einfaches Objekt-Hierarchie-Modell, was sinnvoll ist und normalerweise häufig vorkommt, was man leicht nachvollziehen kann, um einfach mal den Unterschied zu dem normalen Klassenmodell zu verstehen?
Also, was so ein Beispiel wäre, wenn ich jetzt eine Klasse hätte, wäre für einen Hund. Da würde man ja normalerweise hingehen und sagen, ich habe irgendwie Methoden, die ich da heranschreibe, wie Pinkeln und Bällen und so was. Und dann brauche ich davon eine Instanz. Und jetzt bringe ich dem was bei, irgendwie Frisbee fangen. Jetzt kann ja dieser Hund, na, der hat das aber nicht. Und wenn ich in die Klasse reinschreibe, dann könnten ja auf einmal alle Hunde Frisbee fangen. Können sie aber gar nicht. Jetzt kann ich mir, wenn ich jetzt so in Java denken würde, unglaublich komplizierte Sachen, wie Decorator-Pattern oder so ausdenken, um sozusagen irgendwie ohne unglaublich viele Klassen so einen Frisbee-Catching-Dog-Factory-Factory abstract zu machen.
Man stellt sich vor, man schlägt sein Biologiebuch auf, und dann hat man dann so Hunderassen, und dann so Hunderassen mit Frisbee fangen.
Genau, das geht halt nicht. Dann hat man ja auch noch den Frisbee-Fang der Katze, und dann hat man wieder Code-Duplizierung, das ist blöd. Und das ist halt in JavaScript gar kein Problem. Ich mache das einfach genauso. Ich definiere da so eine Funktion für Dog, und der hat irgendwie diese Properties standardmäßig. Und dann bringe ich dem das bei, und dann tue ich da halt hinterher einfach noch die Frisbee-Catch-Methode mit dazu.
Schreibt man ins Objekt direkt rein. Die aber letztlich auch ein Verweis auf eine andere Methode ist, sozusagen. Also in diesem Hund schreibe ich rein, du kannst jetzt irgendwie Catch Frisbee machen. Die Funktion longert sowieso schon irgendwo rum und wird dann in dem Moment auch...
Genau, ich mache sie neu, ist ja völlig egal. Ich sage einfach sozusagen, der Hund heißt irgendwie... Wie heißt denn der Hund? Bob.
Bob, Bob, Bob.
Und dann schreibe ich Fifi Punkt Catch Frisbee ist gleich Funktion. Und dann schreibe ich sie rein.
Sprich, man geht eigentlich dazu über, sich seine Funktionalitäten einfach so von Hand zu stricken. Und fängt man dann nicht irgendwann an, so ein Klassenmodell zu vermissen? Ist das nicht eigentlich schon mal auch eine ganz gute Idee gewesen?
Ja, und es wird ja überhaupt nicht ausgeschlossen. Also es gibt sehr viele so Class-Bilder für JavaScript, wo man halt so klassische objektorientierte Patterns einfach einsetzen kann. Und da hindert einen ja niemand dran, weil das prototypische Modell ist ja im Grunde ein Superset der klassenbasierten Objektorientierung, weil ich damit alles bauen kann, was ich mit klassenbasierter Objektorientierung bauen kann. Andersherum geht das halt nicht. Und dadurch kann man ganz klassisch, also wirklich klassisch objektorientiert damit programmieren. Und wenn man so ein Framework hat, was einem dabei hilft, dann...
Verstehe, das heißt JavaScript ist sozusagen, sagt, okay Leute, ihr wollt Objekte haben, ihr wollt Methoden haben, ihr wollt eine dynamische Programmiersprache haben, ihr hättet gerne Funktionalfunktionen, sollen irgendwie First Class Object sein, geben wir euch. Aber so dieses Denkmodell von Klassen, das ist bei uns nur eine Option. Und wenn du das haben willst, dann musst du das erst mal selber bauen oder du schnappst ja halt irgendein Framework. Aber es kann auch gut sein, dass du ohne das auskommst. Das reduziert sozusagen den Slack. Man muss ja auch bedenken, JavaScript ist eine Programmiersprache, die war, wann war das eigentlich? 94, 95? Kam das sozusagen in die Browser. Wenn wir mal so ein bisschen zurückspulen, was vor 15 Jahren die Leistungsfähigkeit von einem Webbrowser war, die man sich von dem Betriebssystem und den Computern beigelände. Und dass sozusagen jede Webseite in vollständige Programmiersprachen Interpreter nochmal mitatmet, wird glaube ich relativ schnell klar, dass man das eben so leichtgewichtig halten möchte, wie möglich. Und das ist unter anderem durch dieses Prototypenmodell geschaffen worden. Und hat sich dabei sozusagen eine mega abstrakte Programmiersprache geschaffen.
Genau, das ist halt nicht jedermanns Sache, weil man es halt auch nicht so unbedingt gelernt hat.
Das ist ja in dem Sinne auch jetzt auch keine Erfindung von JavaScript. Es gab ja auch schon andere Programmiersprachen, die dieses Modell haben. So die ersten, die mir in die Sendung kommen. Also Sun hat glaube ich mal dieses Self rausgebracht. Und auch der Newton, der Apple Newton, der erste PDA, kam serienmäßig mit NewtonScript, was auch Prototypenbasiert war. Kann man sagen, dass das jetzt so ein neuer Trend ist in der Programmiersprachenwelt, dass man da jetzt wieder so back to the roots sagt, ja, das mit den Klassen, das war zwar jetzt mal ein schöner Ansatz, aber das ist ja viel zu spezifisch.
Also ich würde da noch nicht von einem Trend sprechen, weil das auch irgendwie niemand kopiert.
Aber das kann sich ja jetzt auch schnell ändern. Ich meine, wenn jetzt wirklich mal so ein... Wie ist denn das eigentlich in ActionScript gewesen? War es da genauso?
Das ist genauso, das ist ganz genauso. Aber in ActionScript 3 gibt es sozusagen ein Klassenmodell. also da gibt es sicher auch unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu. Ich glaube, dass in vielen Programmen ist halt sozusagen diese prototypische Denken, macht es halt keinen so einen Ausschlag. Also das funktionale Aspekte von JavaScript sind da halt wichtiger. Um Programme zu schreiben. Und auch zeigen mehr nach vorne, als ob man jetzt unbedingt alles umschmeißen muss und auf Prototypen umzusteigen.
Können wir hier mal Licht anmachen?
Ja klar.
Das wird nämlich ein bisschen dunkel. Das nehme ich dann auch raus. Läuft doch gut. Ich geh noch ein bisschen auf Sprachen ein und dann können wir auch wieder so zu diesem Jason und tra la la nochmal zurückkommen und dann nochmal die Frameworks irgendwie abklappern. So, was gibt es denn außer Dynamik und Funktionalität und diesen Prototypen-Modell noch zu berichten? Meine andere Programmiersprache haben jetzt, was weiß ich, so bestimmte, also was weiß ich, Java zeichnet ja so dieses, also einerseits hat ja Java dieses Klassenmodell, andererseits hat es ja auch gepaart mit diesem Klassenmodell auch gleich so ein Packaging-Konzept, wie kommen sozusagen einzelne Komponenten in so ein System und können mit anderen Komponenten zusammenarbeiten. Damit sind dann meistens auch bei anderen Programmiersprachen so Sachen wie, weiß ich nicht genau, wie es bei Java läuft, Namespaces und ähnliche Sachen verbunden. Gibt es solche Elemente auch in Javascript oder ist das auch wiederum alles komplett offen gelassen?
Also, Language-Konstrukte gibt es gar nicht. Eine Möglichkeit zum Beispiel Namespaces zu simulieren ist, dass man einfach...
Also es gibt natürlich ein Namespace, aber es gibt nur einen, oder was?
Ja, also es gibt vom Scoping her, gibt es erstmal einen globalen Scope.
Das heißt, Variable-Namen und Funktionsnamen sind alle im gleichen Topf. Ich kann nicht eine Variable haben, die so heißt wie eine Funktion?
Nein, es gibt erstmal einen globalen Scope. Also es gibt erstmal Scoping, das hat ja mit Namespaces nichts zu tun.
Ja, wo sozusagen etwas sichtbar ist.
Genau, und da ist es so, dass es sozusagen einen globalen Scope gibt, und dann hat jede Funktion ihren eigenen Scope. Und was man machen kann, um Namespaces zu simulieren und auch tut, ist, dass man einfach sagt, ich habe ein Object und das ist ein Property, das sind halt die Namespace-Kindern. Und dann kann ich, wenn ich jetzt so einen klassischen Java-Namespace haben will, wie irgendwie com.google.projectname oder so, dann kann ich einfach eine Variable-Declaration, die com heißt, und dann kann ich den Property Google rein tun, dann mache ich dann nochmal ein Property mit Project Name und dann macht das Property von meinem Klassennamen. Dann kann ich sozusagen so etwas bauen, dass ich Namespaces habe, die sich so anfühlen wie in anderen Programmiensprachen. Aber das ist wieder halt sozusagen zum Selberbasteln. Da brauche ich halt wieder, wenn ich keinen Bock habe auf Selberbasteln, brauche ich halt ein Framework, was das eingebaut hat.
Aber es ist eigentlich so ein bisschen Legoland, also man ist da wirklich und es gibt irgendwie Zweierer und Vierer und Achter und das war es dann irgendwie.
Was halt vielleicht auf Sprachebene noch wichtig ist, das ist halt wie in den funktionalen Programmiersprachen üblich, gibt es halt Closures, also sprich...
Anonyme Funktionen.
Anonyme Funktionen, die auf lexikal höher gelegene Scopes zugreifen können und auf deren Variablen zugreifen können.
Das heißt, ich kann einer Funktion eine Funktion mitgeben und die kann auf die Variablen zugreifen, die sichtbar waren, als sie deklariert wurde. Und damit kann man sozusagen einen dynamischen State da hinein werfen und später benutzen.
Closures sind ja sozusagen, Objekte kann man ja beschreiben als Daten mit Verhalten. Und Closure ist sozusagen Verhalten, weil es ja einfach eine Funktion ist, die auf Daten zugreifen kann.
Das heißt JavaScript ist eigentlich, wir haben ja schon fast alle wichtigen Buzzwords irgendwie drin, es ist eine dynamische Sprache. Das heißt, es gibt keine statischen Typen, es gibt keine Festlegung. Jeder Name kann zur Laufzeit alles Mögliche binden, kann auf eine Funktion zeigen, zehn Minuten später kann er auch eine Zahl zeigen und danach wieder auf einen String. Ist egal, sozusagen alles ist irgendwie im Fluss, es gibt keine Festlegung, was ja auch die schon anfangs erwähnten Grundprobleme erst mal mit sich bringt, so eine Sprache dann auch performant zu machen und wo, glaube ich, auch so diese ganzen Versuche, dann doch so statische Elemente mit reinzubringen, auch verortet werden müssen, dass dann irgendwie Leute meinen, naja, das kriegen wir ja nie schnell, wenn das nicht irgendwie statisch ist oder kriegen wir nie irgendwie so einfach geinterface. Lass mal lieber weg mit diesem dynamischen Zeug, das ist irgendwie alles bäh. Wo dann die Puristen kommen und sagen, ihr habt ja wohl nicht mal alle hier, dynamisch ist die Zukunft. So, dann haben wir das Funktionale bis hin eben zu Closures, das was ja auch so Lisp und so weiter auszeichnet. Wer das interessiert, jetzt kann ich zwischendurch mal wieder meine eigene Sendung hier bewerben. Gibt es zwei Sendungen bei Chaosradio Express, die in dem Zusammenhang mal ganz interessant sind. Einerseits habe ich mal eine über Lisp gemacht, Chaosradio Express 84 mit Hans Hübner, sehr interessant, wo dann sozusagen mal die Mutter aller Poemiersprachen genau auseinandergenommen wird. Und so die abstrakte Weltsicht, gerade so mit Closures etc. kommt ausgesprochen ausführlich daher noch ein bisschen länger her. Chaosradio Express 31 Poemiersprachen und Dillen, wo wir also sowohl über Poemiersprachen im Allgemeinen, als auch Dillen im Besonderen geredet haben. So, jetzt aber mal wieder zurück von dem Ausflug in die Sprache. Also wir lernen, eigentlich ist ja AvaScript eine sehr moderne Sprache und es bringt eine ganze Menge von dem, was lange verpönt war, weil es irgendwie angeblich ja so langsam und so kompliziert ist, mit sich wie Funktionalität, Dynamik, hat aber auf der anderen Seite ist es auch so minimalistisch, dass es einerseits sehr leichtgewichtig ist, andererseits aber auch im Prinzip allen Modellen, wie man denn jetzt so seine Daten innerhalb des Programms organisieren möchte, die Tür offen lässt. Ich das richtig sehe, du hast ja auch schon erwähnt, du hast so ein Meta-Object-Library-Framework geschrieben namens JOOS. Das klingt sich ja im Prinzip dann auch auf dieser Ebene ein.
Ja, das ist sozusagen ein Versuch, der geklappt hat, ein Meta-Object-Modell in JavaScript zu bauen. Also ein Modell zur Beschreibung des Objektsystems. Richtig, das ist ja halt ein Meta-Modell, das auch ein Interface bereitstellt, um sozusagen Objekte zu verändern zur Laufzeit. Was sozusagen einfach reichhaltiger ist als das von JavaScript. Aber im Wesentlichen ist es natürlich JavaScript. Also das sind ganz normale JavaScript-Objekte, die nur halt ein Meta-Modell haben.
Was kann man damit machen?
Also man kann halt sagen, okay, ich tu jetzt nicht nur so, ich hab jetzt eine Klasse, weil ich will jetzt mit Klassen arbeiten. Und das Ding hat halt einen Namen, was in JavaScript erstmal super problematisch ist. Weil man kann einem Konstruktor, einer Funktion, halt keinen Namen geben. Hat sie halt nicht.
Also die Funktion hat schon einen Namen, aber...
Genau, aber das weiß sie ja nicht selbst. Das ist schon, ist so. Das ist eher was für Debugger, dass man das in Stack Trace anzeigen kann, aber die Funktion weiß halt nicht, wie sie heißt. Und das Ding hat einen Namen, das hat irgendwie Instanzvariablen, das hat Methoden. Dann gibt es da so Sachen, um zu vererben in JavaScript ist nicht so pretty. Und man kann so moderne Aspekte nutzen, wie zum Beispiel mit Trades zu arbeiten, was dann eine Mischung ist aus einem Mixin und einem Interface. Man kann aspektorientiert programmieren, also Aspekte an Methoden reinschreiben, und so viele Geschichten, die man alle in JavaScript kann, die aber unglaublich kompliziert sind, wenn man sie aus dem Legop-Kasten selbst zusammen bastelt, gehen damit sehr einfach und deklarativ hinzuschreiben.
Wird das auch schon verwendet? Gibt es andere, sind mit JOOS off-the-shelf-Klassensysteme, nach dem Motto, wenn du so ein Klassenmodell wie bei Java haben willst, dann nimm das und das basiert auf JOOS oder wenn du ein Klassenmodell haben willst wie bei Smalltalk, dann nimm das und das basiert auch auf JOOS? Muss man sich das so vorstellen oder gehe ich da wirklich selber ran und baue mir einfach das, was ich haben möchte?
Es gibt sozusagen so, da gibt es eine Funktion, die heißt class. In dem Fall ist ein Parameter halt ein Name und dann eine Beschreibung. Und der dann wieder die Instandsvariate Methoden usw. vorkommt und baut den dann so wie eine Standardklasse in JOOS halt gedacht ist. Wenn du eine eigene, wenn du sagst, ich will aber jetzt ein anderes Klassenmodell haben, dann kannst du das überall, dann baust du dir halt eine eigene Meterklasse.
Also was ich möchte jetzt zum Beispiel Mehrfach-Vererbung haben oder so Mix-Innen, hast du ja schon erwähnt.
Genau, dann baue ich das halt, dann baue ich eine eigene Meterklasse. Also was ich zum Beispiel in einem Objekt habe, ich habe eine Meterklasse, in meinem letzten Objekt gebaut, für meine Controller im Frontend. Die deklarieren nicht nur Methoden, die sie haben, sondern die deklarieren auch Custom-Events, auf die sie hören. Also sozusagen Events, die in der Seite passieren. Das gibt es ja im normalen Objekt-Modell, kann ich sowas ja nicht. Und sowas kann ich dann damit machen.
Gut, also wir könnten das jetzt hier noch ewig fortführen, aber ich glaube, das ist dann auch besser aufgehoben, dass man sich wirklich mal so die Manuals anschaut. Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne noch mal so ein bisschen zurückkommen auf diese Framework-Geschichte, weil ich so den Eindruck gehabt habe, dass da also Framework und auch so diese generellen, diese Programmiermodelle, die sich da eben, die da so entstehen. Wir waren ja vorhin so ein bisschen hängen geblieben, so bei Prototype und bei Ajax. Ich glaube, da müssen wir noch mal so ein paar Klammern schließen und das irgendwie auch noch mal so ein bisschen rund machen. Vielleicht noch mal so zur Zusammenfassung. Also es gab halt mal dieses HTTP-Request-Objekt, was komischerweise XML-Http-Request-Objekt hieß, in JScript, also in der Microsoft-Implementierung von JavaScript im Internet Explorer. Und irgendwann später ist mal jemand auf die Idee gekommen, hey, das ist ja toll, da kann man ja so ein paar Sachen mitmachen. Das nennen wir jetzt irgendwie Ajax und erst mal das Großgeschrieb, jetzt das Kleingeschrieb, zumindest das Jax, wenn auch nicht das A. Und irgendwann ist man auch dazu übergegangen, dieses X nicht mehr ganz so wahrzunehmen, sondern die ganze Kommunikation zwischen dem Server und dem Client auch mit JavaScript zu machen, wenn ich es richtig sehe, oder?
Ja, also was üblich ist sozusagen im Ajax-Transport, ist das, was auch gerade aus der Rails-Welt viel genutzt wurde, dass man auf einen Client HTML nachlädt und der jetzt einfach an die Seite knallt und der das Server sozusagen das Rendering weiterhin übernimmt. Und was sich ansonsten als sozusagen Datenformat wirklich vollständig durchgesetzt hat, ist JSON, kurz JavaScript Object Notation. Und das ist ein Datenformat, sozusagen gefunden von Douglas Crockford, der und basiert sozusagen die Eigenschaft ist, dass es sind valide JavaScript-Literale, die ich sozusagen das Parsen von JSON kann ich in JavaScript machen, indem ich eval aufruf und den JSON-String übergebe. Und dann kriege ich halt einfach das Object zurück, was da repräsentiert ist.
Eval ist auch ein Standard-Feature von JavaScript. Das heißt, man kann zur Laufzeit einfach einen String nehmen und sagen, hier Compiler, mach da mal wieder Code raus.
Das gibt es in allen Implementierungen außer ActionScript. Es ist vielleicht gar nicht so eine gute Idee, JSON so zu parsen, aber es geht halt. Das ist halt, weil dieses JavaScript ist ein Subset von JavaScript, was die Literal für Objects, Arrays, Zahlen und Strings und True und False beinhaltet. Und auch nur das sozusagen, also es ist nicht Turing-complete, es ist halt nur dieses Literal.
Also nur für so normale Datenschrukturen.
Genau und ich kann es halt, es kann halt nichts kaputt machen.
Also man kann ja keinen Code reininitieren oder so.
Genau, das ist halt nicht erlaubt. Und es gibt im Wesentlichen für jede Programmi-Sprache auf der Welt Implementierung, um das so zu parsen und zu erzeugen.
Das heißt, es ist mindestens genauso komfortabel wie XML, aber eigentlich sogar noch komfortabler, weil es nicht so einen hohen syntaktischen Aufwand hat.
Ja, vor allem hat man halt keinen Impedance-Mismatch, weil das super eng passt an die Objekte, die ich sowieso in meinem Programm habe. XML eignet sich meines Erachtens nicht besonders gut, um Datenstrukturen aus Software abzubilden. Es gibt auch Sachen, die super gut mit XML gehen, aber das halt gerade nicht. Deswegen fühlt sich JSON normalerweise wesentlich natürlicher an, um so Allerweltsprobleme, die ich jeden Tag habe, zu lösen.
Und es ist generisch genug, dass es auch für andere Programmersprachen als ausreichend in der Beschreibung dient. So. Das heißt, da hat sich jetzt eine neue Kultur entwickelt eigentlich auf Basis von diesem AJAX, was ja dann auch auf die Anwendung eine Riesenauswirkung hatte. Ich kann mich noch ganz gut erinnern, als das dann irgendwie losging. Auf einmal wurde das Web auf einmal fluid, auf einmal hatte man irgendwie das Gefühl, dass diese Turnaround-Zeiten, die man früher immer so hatte, mit irgendwie, ich möchte diese Tabelle aber jetzt sortiert haben, und dann klickt man da irgendwie drauf und dann geht der ganze Request nochmal zum Server und dann denkt der Server, wenn man mich darüber nach, wie er diese Tabelle sortieren könnte, dann kriegt er dann irgendwann die Antwort. Das ging dann zunehmend in Maße hin, dass da irgendwie alles im Web-Browser stattfand. Also das mag jetzt nicht unbedingt mit diesem AJAX zusammenhängen, aber es war irgendwie die Zeit und auf einmal wurde dann quasi auch der Client wieder neu entdeckt. Das war so mein Eindrufe, dass du dem zustimmst. Es gab ja dann auch diese ersten Eye-Candy-Projekte, wie, wie ist das, Scriptaculous? Das basiert aber auch auf diesem Prototype, oder?
Genau, das ist eine Erweiterung vom Prototype, um sozusagen Effekte sowie irgendwie Sachen zu bewegen und mit Fäden ein- und auszublenden und sowas.
Das heißt, man kann sagen, so Prototype, Scriptaculous und diese ganze Welt war im Prinzip so eine Art JavaScript-Wundertüte.
Genau.
Das konnte man dann irgendwie nehmen und auf einmal war es irgendwie alles nicht mehr so kalt und es zog nicht mehr im Flur, weil ich musste nicht 30.000 verschiedene Varianten browserfern zu bedienen, mir erlernen, sondern das ganze Datenmodell an der Webseite zu ändern, hatte jetzt nur noch eine einziges Interface und dieses JavaScript-Framework, was ja relativ klein ist, Framework klingt immer gleich so riesig, aber das ist ja ein recht schlankes Gebilde, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Man muss ja auch auf Ladezeit achten.
Man muss es ja auch laden, genau, ich weiß nicht, wie groß mag das gewesen sein, 60, 100K oder so was?
Ja, genau, so war es in der Größenordnung.
Das war wohl mal viel, heutzutage fällt das nicht mehr groß ins Gewicht, wenn man sich anschaut, was so an Grafiken und Filmen geladen wird und ja, auf einmal bewegte sich was. Also ich hatte auch so den Eindruck, oh man, da bewegt sich jetzt überhaupt mal was. Weil es ja eigentlich seit JavaScript geboren wurde, da passierte dann erstmal zehn Jahre lang eigentlich fast nichts. Ja, okay, es gab so Rollovers hier und ein paar Menüs da, aber irgendwie so im Großen und Ganzen war das nicht. Wie ging das jetzt weiter? Es ist ja seitdem noch eine ganze Menge anderes Framework-Material dazu gekommen. Was waren die Lehren aus Prototype?
Du sagtest ja schon so, dass irgendwie das falsch gemacht worden ist. Die Idee, die Standard-Objekte zu erweitern, hat sich als problematisch herausgestellt. Aber die Lehren daraus sind so, dass Interfaces eher extern sind, also dass man, wenn ich jetzt ein Iterator baue, dass ich dann eher den Array in der Funktion übergebe und dann auch noch ein Iterator dazu, statt das irgendwie zu eng zu koppeln. Aber davon abgesehen, also gibt es eh auch ganz andere Ansätze, nennenswert. Also ich glaube, jetzt mit Abstand das wichtigste Framework im Web-Client ist halt jQuery von John Razik, was im Grunde so eine Art, manche Leute nennen es Domain-Specific Language, um Dom-Manipulation zu machen, wo man sehr knapp und mit wenig Code sehr viel erreichen kann. Und das ganze Ding basiert auf zwei Ideen. Einmal sozusagen, dass Dom-Operationen so eine Art Mengen-Operation sind. Also ich selektiere hier mit CSS, Selektor, Syntax, Dom-Elemente und habe dann ein Objekt, was zurückkommt. Nicht irgendwie ein Array, sondern ein Objekt kommt zurück. Und wenn ich jetzt sozusagen auf diesem Objekt die Methode hide aufrufe, dann werden alle Objekte, die returned, die von diesem Selektor erfasst wurden, halt weggemacht. Und wenn ich show aufrufe, werden die wieder eingeblendet. Ich muss da nicht über das Result-Set irgendwie iterieren und jeden einzelnen einen ausblenden, sondern es geht immer auf der Menge.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie zehn HTML-Elemente in meiner Seite habe, die alle irgendwie mit, was weiß ich, class gleich foobar markiert sind, als naja, das sind halt die, die irgendwie wie foobar sind, dann kann ich irgendwie sagen, okay, selektiere mir jetzt mal alle foobars, einfach so in CSS-Hintags, was so viel wie Punkt foobar wäre. Und dann kann ich sagen, irgendwie hide und dann sind die alle weg.
Und das witzige ist halt, dass hide auch wieder dieses Objekt repräsentiert, äh, returned und man dann so Method-Chaining machen kann. Also immer noch irgendwie noch ein paar CSS-Route reinsetzen und die nach rechts bewegen und dann nach links und nach oben, das ist alles.
Das heißt, das ist auch ein relativ sexy Interface zur Webseite, so wie man es eigentlich auch als Webdesigner gewohnt ist, also halt einfach mit CSS. Während irgendwie Prototype einfach im Prinzip erst mal nur versucht hat zu fixen, was vorher irgendwie vollkommen distorted war, aber immer noch sich im Prinzip an dieser Logik, was diese Dom-APIs, die machten auf mich immer so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, wie so das Werkzeug, was mit Ikea-Möbeln irgendwie mit nach Hause kommt. Damit kriegt man die Schraube zwar irgendwie reingedreht, aber man ist doch froh, wenn man seinen eigenen Werkzeugkasten zur Hand hat, weil es irgendwie eine Zumutung ist.
Genau, das ist bei jQuery sicher viel heiler, wobei sozusagen diese CSS-Selektoren, das haben jetzt auch alle anderen Frameworks adaptiert, weil das sich wirklich als sehr gute Idee herausgestellt hat. Nennswert ist sicher auch Dojo.
Warte mal, ist das alles, was jQuery macht? Also jQuery ist sozusagen ein Framework, was mir nur einen anderen Zugang zu meiner Dom-Welt bietet. Das heißt, es spielt auch nur in einer Webseite eine Rolle.
Richtig, es gibt noch ein bisschen Helper für IAX, noch ein paar Utilities, aber im Wesentlichen ist es rein ein Dom-Interface. Alles klar. Deswegen kam ich gerade auf Dojo, was auch diesen Teil anbietet. Zusätzlich halt so ein bisschen, so eine Art, das Missing SDK, also halt so eine gesamte Fülle von Funktionen, die man halt irgendwie mal braucht. Also so ein Web-Service-Interface, dafür halt eine Implementierung. Die muss man sich normalerweise ja in JavaScript irgendwo irgendwie selber bauen, weil es nicht standardmäßig dabei ist, dass es da halt drin ist. So würde ich das karakterisieren, um das auch zu differenzieren. Dann halt YUI.
Warte mal, also wenn ich Dojo nehme, dann brauche ich jQuery nicht mehr. Das heißt, es ist eher so eine Geschmacksfrage, was man dann so nimmt?
Ja, Geschmacksfrage, ja.
Die meisten entscheiden sich für welchen Geschmack? Also das ist sozusagen derzeit eigentlich so der Goldstandard erstmal.
Das ist das, was die meisten benutzen. Es hat dazukommen, dass sehr viel Corporate-Support mittlerweile dahintersteht. John selbst arbeitet beim Mozilla und macht das auch so für sich. Aber es ist zum Beispiel Standard in dem neuen MVC-Framework von Microsoft und Nokia-Intelligence ein und so. Das setzt sich da wirklich durch und ist halt auch gut für diesen genau einen Zweck, den es erfüllt. Wenn man eine große Anwendung baut, dann braucht man noch mehr Frameworks als JQuery dafür.
Aber man braucht auf jeden Fall das Minimum, dass man überhaupt erst mal halbwegs entspannt auf den Inhalt der Webseite zugreifen kann.
Genau, das erfüllt das halt perfekt.
Verstehe. So, YUI hast du erwähnt. Was ist das für ein?
Das ist auch nochmal wieder ein Framework, was sich auch primär mit dem Thema DOM auseinandersetzt. Und dann vor allem sich dadurch kennzeichnen, dass es viele Bidgets gibt, um irgendwie einen Date Picker zu bauen. Oder eine sortierbare Liste und solche Sachen sind da halt standardmäßig drin, die man dann halt noch erweitern kann.
Das heißt, hier geht es dann auch schon so in die Richtung. Steckt da irgendwie auch mit im Namen, YUI. Das steht wahrscheinlich für User Interface, vermute ich mal. Dass man im Prinzip auch schon so den Weg verfolgt, richtige Anwendungen zu machen, die User Interface-Vereinheitlichungen mit sich bringen. Kann man das so sagen?
Das steckt da auf jeden Fall drin, ja. Also es ist jetzt noch nicht der, es ist kein Framework, um so Single-Page-Apps zu bauen, die komplett auch im Browser gerendert werden, wie jetzt zum Beispiel Gmail oder ganz viel anderen Kram von Google, sondern eher noch in einem klassischen Ding gedacht und einfach auch, also es ist halt nicht, da ist kein Framework drin, um so eine App zu bauen. Aber es geht auf jeden Fall in die Richtung.
Und was für eine Bedeutung hat YUI? Ist das jetzt nur so yet another Framework, was man jetzt auch mal nehmen kann? Oder ist das schon so irgendwas, wo sich dann viele Leute drum scharen?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall yet another Framework, würde ich schon sagen, aber es ist trotzdem auch relativ verbreitet.
Du magst es? Nein.
Nicht so, aber ich hab auch nichts dagegen. Viele Kollegen von mir setzen das ein.
Und was magst du?
Ich mag JQuery, ich mag Dojo auch. Muss halt immer das Richtige nehmen, was gerade irgendwie den Nagel in die Wand reintut.
Aber jetzt sind ja in letzter Zeit auch, also es gibt ja eine ganze Batterie von JavaScript-Frameworks, die irgendwie auf einen dir schlagen. Ich hab da irgendwie mal so einen schönen Post, allein schon die ganze Masse an JavaScript-Frameworks, die allein da bei Apple eingesetzt werden. Eins davon geht ja schon in die Richtung, wie du eben angedeutet hast. Es gibt diese Sprout Core, sagt dir das was? Damit sind ja dann auch schon so etwas umfangreichere Web-Anwendungen umgesetzt, also bis hin zu einem Mail-Client. Also diese ganze Mobile-Me-Suite zum Beispiel ist da mitgemacht worden. Spielt Sprout Core über Apple hinaus irgendeine Rolle, oder ist das nun wirklich nur wieder deren Ansatz?
Spielt sicher eine Rolle, also es gibt andere, die das einsetzen, das ist jetzt noch nicht so richtig explodiert, weil ja auch, also das Webpage-Paradigma können wir, ich weiß nicht ob leider, also vielleicht ist es auch eine gute Idee und man sollte es gar nicht wegwerfen. Es gibt sicher Cases, wo ich mit Sprout Core gut arbeiten kann, aber das ungelöste Problem ist, wenn ich auf Google angewiesen bin, um mir Traffic zu schicken, dann brauche ich adressierbare Seiten, die in Suchergebnissen stehen können. Und das habe ich halt nicht, wenn ich so eine Single-Page-Application baue.
Das heißt also Sprout Core ist sozusagen ein Vertreter, das Framework-Modell, was Sprout Core aufmacht, ist ja schon sehr ähnlich zu Desktop-Frameworks, wie sie bei Mac OS 10 oder eben unter Windows auch der Fall sind.
Ich glaube, interessanter als darf und viel radikaler ist halt Cappuccino, die irgendwas getan haben, wo man normalerweise sagen würde, ich habe Angst, das zu machen und mache es deswegen nicht. Und dann haben sie festgestellt, dass es gar nicht so schwer ist. Sie haben sich eine neue Programmiersprache ausgedacht, Objective-J. Das ist so, wie Objective-C zu C ist, also man hat ein Objective-C ähnlichen Syntax und kann halt drumherum JavaScript programmieren, wenn man muss oder will und haben dann das gesamte Cocoa-Framework von Apple zu dieser Plattform migriert und das geht so weit, dass man ein Interface-Bilder auf dem Mac in Xcode, ein Interface bauen kann, da haben sie einen kleinen Cross-Compiler zu Objective-J und der Format und dann kann man diese Anwendung im EE7 starten. Das ist total abgefahren und die haben wirklich, also wesentliche Teile von Cocoa, die haben sie portiert und...
Aber blutet da dem JavaScript-Puristen nicht so ein bisschen das Herz?
Ja, natürlich, aber wenn man sich die Anwendungen anguckt, die die damit bauen, also die berühmte ist, ist sicher 360slides.com. Das ist halt eine Portierung von Keynote in dem Browser, die teilweise sogar cooler ist als Keynote. So because you can-mäßig wird halt sozusagen der Thumbnail-View von der Slide auf der linken Seite in Echtzeit geupdatet und solche Features halt, die man einfach nur aus Anwendungen halt vom Desktop-Client kennt. Natürlich kommen also diese ganzen Skills von früher, werden jetzt wieder extrem wertvoll. So wie man so client-anwendungsfähig sein kann ja, das kann ja der klassische Web-Entwickler gar nicht. Der weiß ja nicht, wie sowas geht. Da ist es noch viel, viel offen.
Das heißt, der eigentliche Kampf ist so ein bisschen, was will man jetzt eigentlich? Will man so Web-Anwendungen haben, die sich als Seiten, als durchsuchbare, recherchierbare, indizierbare, googelbare Seiten abbilden, so wie man das irgendwie klassisch kennt? Oder fungiert das Web nicht, ja, oder im Sinne von nicht, dass es das ersetzt, oder könnte man nicht halt auch damit vollständige Applikations-Delivery machen?
Also man kann auf jeden Fall. Ja, es geht auf jeden Fall. Es macht nicht immer Sinn, aber wenn man Use-Case hat, wo es Sinn macht, so eine App zu bauen, dann funktioniert das super damit. Und es kommen jetzt sozusagen, auch die Rahmenwerke, die darauf hinzielen, werden halt jetzt immer stabiler. Es ist noch, man muss schon sagen, es ist noch sehr im Aufbau. Noch so ein Case von einem Cross-Compiler ist ja am GWT, Google Web Toolkit, die ja das Gleiche für Java machen, wo ich in so einer klassischen Java-Umgebung meine Anwendung baue und dann die Teile dem Kleinen laufen, zu JavaScript-Komplett werden. Das kann man als JavaScript-Purist auch blöd finden, aber es macht sicher für gewisse Anwendungen und wenn ich auch Entwickler mit einem gewissen Scale-Side habe, macht es sicher Sinn, das so zu machen.
Wo geht denn jetzt die Reise hin mit JavaScript? Man ist jetzt auch aus der Beobachtung dieser sich revitalisierenden Entwickler-Szene, der Vision, dass man durchaus auch auf der Server-Seite was rocken kann und da vielleicht auch mittel- oder langfristig nicht unbedingt jetzt so sehr der Funktionsvielfalt von Java nachstehen muss, deshalb tut man das sicherlich, aber es gibt ja in dem Sinne keinen technischen Grund, warum das nicht so ist, zumindest sehe ich keinen. Was siehst du denn so für Bewegungen im Webmarkt oder überhaupt im Web? Welche Rolle wird JavaScript spielen? Auch vielleicht im Hinblick auf die Rolle, die ist jetzt bei so Systemen wie dem Palm, sicherlich demnächst auch bei Symbian, Maemo, also allen nicht-iPhone-mobilen OSen spielen wird als Applikationsumgebung. Die kommen ja auch alle nochmal mit ihren eigenen Frameworks daher.
Ja, also ich finde persönlich vor allem Palm WebOS, ob jetzt einem jetzt die Umsetzung gefällt, ist ein ganz anderes Thema, aber sozusagen die Radikalität von dessen Ansatz ist natürlich wirklich beeindruckend. Die haben ja sozusagen ihre gesamte Oberfläche, ist einfach WebKit und alles, was man da programmieren kann, ist JavaScript. Das ist sozusagen wirklich extrem visionär und ich glaube auch Google muss sich ein bisschen das Gefühl haben, dass sie mit Android wirklich ein bisschen in der Vergangenheit hängen geblieben sind, weil sie mit ChromeOS genau das, was WebOS schon auf dem Handy ist, jetzt für Netbooks bauen wollen und WebOS ist im Grunde das gleiche, vom Gedanken her, wie ChromeOS. Also, dass alles Web-Anwendung ist und dass der Browser sozusagen Dreh- und Angelpunkt dieser Umgebung ist. Was ich da im Mobile-Bereich am interessantesten finde am Augenblick, ist das PhoneGap-Framework. Was ja im Grunde eine JavaScript-Schnittstelle bietet, um Anwendungen zu bauen, die man auf verschiedenen Phones deployen kann. Ich weiß nicht genau, was da im Augenblick alles möglich ist. Core ist iPhone, Android. WebOS ist glaube ich auch fertig. Blackberry ist fertig. Windows Mobile ist fertig. Was die halt tun, ist, man kann damit Anwendungen bauen, also keine Web-Anwendungen. Die bringen einen WebKit-Browser mit, wenn nicht schon einer da ist, also Windows hält. Und sonst nehmen sie halt den, der da ist.
Das heißt, auf einem Windows-Mobile-Phone besteht die Delivery darin, dass man erst mal den Browser ersetzt?
Genau, ja, nicht den Browser ersetzt, sondern dass man eine Anwendung startet, die ein WebKit im Full-Scroll hat und das ist einfach in der Anwendung drin. Die ist dann ein bisschen größer. Und hat dann halt einfach Interfaces zu den ganzen Sachen drin, was so ein Phone halt so hat, so Accelerometer und für Styling und so sind halt diese ganzen APIs einfach nach JavaScript exposed. Dann kann ich halt auf dieser API, ähnlich wie es im Grunde schon die Web-Frameworks für die Browser gemacht haben, einheitlich Anbindung bauen für die verschiedenen Phones. Wobei sicher der Task natürlich noch viel komplizierter ist, aber da steckt auf jeden Fall viel Potenzial drin. Und macht natürlich auch den ganzen Leuten mit ihren Web-Skills die Tür und Tor auf, halt auch mal Anwendung für Mobile zu bauen.
Und wenn man Mobile jetzt mal aus und vor lässt, so auf dem Desktop, das Web-Modell, ich meine, du sagst Google muss sich ein bisschen umdrehen. Ich meine, Google hat jetzt über Jahre hinweg, wie kaum ein anderer, im Prinzip JavaScript-Anwendungen gepusht. Google Maps kam von Anfang an als webkonforme JavaScript-Anwendung daher, während Yahoo! noch alle anderen irgendwie immer noch auf Flash gesetzt haben. Sind die da nicht schon vorne weg?
Nein, die sind natürlich vorne weg. Und ich meinte das vor allem gerade, weil sie mit Chrome OS ja jetzt einfach die Strategie da ein bisschen gewechselt haben und da pushen sie ja genau solche Anwendungen, die im Browser bauen. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall etwas zur Anwendungsentwicklung im Browser, sind wir framework-mäßig noch nicht weit genug und da wird einfach noch viel passieren. Das ist ganz klar. Also da kann man auch, wenn man als Entwickler Bock hat, die Welt zu verändern, kann man da hingehen und da was bauen und dann gibt es dafür einen Markt, weil der ist noch nicht zu.
Sowohl auf dem Client als auch auf der Server-Seite, da hatten wir ja vorhin nur angerissen. Also gibt es da irgendwie solche Hilfen wie Rails? Ist da schon irgendwas in Sicht, wenn man jetzt Anwendungen bauen möchte für das Web?
Es hat sich da auf jeden Fall noch nicht irgendwie durchgesetzt oder so, aber es gibt verschiedene Frameworks, die sozusagen entweder auf Nowell oder auf Node halt aufsetzen. So ein 80%-Plon von Rails kann man ja schon mal an so einem guten Wochenende auch bauen und davon gibt es natürlich entsprechend auch viele. Da ist es natürlich viel interessanter, auch mal was anders zu machen. Weil Rails ist ja ein super Framework, also warum sollte ich nicht damit das bauen, wenn ich genau das gleiche in JavaScript tun muss?
Jetzt kommst du ja selber viel mit Programmierern zusammen, denke ich mal, die alle auch so ihre Lieblingsprogrammiersprache haben und wenn du dann irgendwie den Mantel aufmachst und sagst, ich mache JavaScript, dann hast du da sicherlich mehr als nur einmal irgendwie einen schrägen Blick geerntet, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal. Was sind denn so die klassischen Fragen und Bedenken, die so die anderen Programmierer gegenüber JavaScript als Sprache und Plattformen entgegenbringen und was hast du da für Antworten?
Also viele haben ja einfach schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht, dadurch, dass es früher so ein Krampfer mit dem Browser zu interagieren, aber da kann man relativ schnell einfach zeigen, dass die Zeit einfach vorbei ist und dass das jetzt halt weg ist. Was aber am häufigsten ist, ist natürlich einfach die klassische Diskussion, die aber ja nicht JavaScript-spezifisch ist zwischen dem statischen und der dynamischen Typisierung.
Wobei man sagen kann, dass ja jetzt, was Web-Anwendungen betrifft, naja gut, da gibt es auch noch sowohl viel Java, als aber eben auch eine ganze Menge Python und PHP. Meine PHP macht ja eigentlich das meiste aus.
Ich komme halt, also bei der Arbeit sehr viel mit Java-Einwicklern in Kontakt, sonst stellen sich natürlich diese Fragen. Also es muss halt nicht nur aussehen wie eine Ente, sondern es muss halt auch ganz groß dranstehen, dass es eine ist.
Ich bin eine Ente, schönes Bild. Ja, aber du denkst nicht, dass das nötig ist. Hauptsache, es verhält sich wie eine Ente.
Ja, also da kann man ja auch lange drüber diskutieren, aber wie gesagt, das ist ja gar nicht JavaScript-spezifisch, sondern es ist ja ein ganz anderes Thema.
Und das Objektmodell, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dürfte auch noch eine ganze Menge Leute nachts wachhalten, oder?
Ja, aber sobald man halt ein Class-Builder-Framework nutzt, was einem hilft, dann kann man ja zumindest auch sozusagen die breite Masse der Programmierer-Mittelschicht halt darauf konvertieren. Und die fühlen sich dann irgendwie zu Hause.
Ja gut, aber was mich an der Stelle bewegt, ist, meine, selber was hinzubekommen, das ist ja so das eine. Und so, na klar, jetzt kann ich mir irgendwie das Framework nehmen auf My Choice und dann hack ich da halt so mein Kram. Aber dann, da sehe ich so ein bisschen so den Dämon von Perl, ja, die Write-Only-Programmiersprache. Man kann da super drin Code schreiben, aber du kriegst halt die Code-Basen von zwei Programmierern irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Das ist durchaus viel schlimmer als in Perl, oder? Weil, also, in kommerziellen Projekten ist irgendwas zu tun, ohne Framework, mal ich sage es, es ist totales No-Go. Und dann sind natürlich die Quellbasen nicht kompatibel, wenn man versucht, verschiedene Framework-Codes zu nennen.
Ja, weil, also, sowohl die Verwendung von Frameworks, aber es ist denke mal, dadurch entsteht ja auch ein gewisser Coding-Style, eine Art und Weise, mit Konventionen zu arbeiten, etc. Und wenn ich halt nicht in der Lage bin, von anderen Leuten Code, so ohne weiteres zu lernen, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es recht schwierig wird. Ich meine, so, wenn man jetzt mal so als Gegenbeispiel, das weiß ich, Smalltalk oder halt auch Ruby nimmt, die auch alle so mit ihren Konventionen daherkommen und wo denke ich mal eine ganze Menge, weiß jetzt nicht, ob Smalltalk das beste Beispiel ist, bei Ruby war das irgendwie dann auch relativ schnell klar, da gibt es halt so einfach einen Way to go. Es gibt zwar da auch Variabilität, aber im Großen und Ganzen kann ich irgendwie zwei Code-Basen nehmen, gerade weil auch viel sich auf Rails bezieht und das ist dann halt alles sehr übertragbar. Das heißt der Reuse ist dann auch relativ hoch. Das ist ja dann schon ein Problem bei JavaScript. Fragt sich, ob sich das von alleine löst, ob da irgendwas auf dem Weg ist oder ob das noch eine Weile so bleiben wird?
Die CommonJS Bewegung versucht da halt sozusagen Standard zu definieren.
Das können wir dann nochmal drauf eingehen. CommonJS ist so eine Art Standard-Library. So wie CommonLisp sozusagen versucht hat, für Lisp-Value eine Einheit zu schaffen. CommonJS.
Das erste und verbreiteste Feature dieses Standards sozusagen ist die Spezifikation für Module. Dort werden sich Python-Programmierer zu Hause fühlen. Was auch viel damit zusammenhängt, ist, dass die Leute, die da mitmachen, viel so einen Python-Background haben, wo man zumindest gern sieht wird, wie man Module macht. Also Packaging sozusagen einführt. Das ist das Fundamentale, wo es ganz clever ist. Weil man sich darauf einigen kann.
Ja, weil es gibt ja auch nicht so was wie, was weiß ich, bei Perl gibt es halt irgendwie C-Pan. Da habe ich halt so ein automatisiertes, direkt in meine Umgebung integriertes Verzeichnis von Code und kann mal eben mit Install-Name, Tralala, Return, mir sowas installieren. Da gibt es auch nichts Vergleichbares, oder?
Es gibt tatsächlich ja JSON, was auf C-Pan basiert, die gesamte Infrastruktur nutzt.
JSON, also J-S-A-N, oder was? Nicht zu verwechseln mit J-S-O-N.
Hat sich aber nicht durchgesetzt. Ich weiß nicht, die haben es jetzt gerade nochmal wiederbelebt, ist schon ein paar Jahr richtig alt. Und es kommt auch aus dem CommonJS-Umfeld, wird es auch so ein Packaging-System geben. Leider modelliert nach den Modellen von Ruby und Python, die sich im Gegensatz zu CPan nie so richtig, also nie diesen Reifegrad von CPan geschaffen haben.
Also so Jam zum Beispiel jetzt in der Ruby-Welt.
Ist halt nicht so ein Fire-and-Forget-Tool wie CPan. Weil das Ganze ist halt nicht zentralisiert. Ist natürlich aber immer leichter, eine nicht zentralisierte Lösung zu etablieren. Was zentralisiert ist, kann man sich in JavaScript ja gar nicht vorstellen. Weil es hier gibt ja keinen Larry Wall, der sagt, wir machen das jetzt halt so.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt community-wise. Stimmt, dass du das ansprichst. Der Benevolent-Dictator.
Das ist halt Brian Dahl bei Node.js. Und deswegen ist es auch so, wie es ist. Aber in anderen Projekten, also in Common.js gibt es das gar nicht. Brandon Icke selbst, also der Erfinder von JavaScript, spielt eigentlich nur eine ganz kleine Rolle.
Hat er keinen Bock mehr drauf?
Wenig Öffentlichkeit. Also geht zur ECMAScript-Meeting so. Glaub ich ehrlich gesagt nur, weiß ich gar nicht.
Ist so ein Kellernat.
Ich habe ihn halt noch nie getroffen.
Der darf nur einmal im Monat raus.
Dass ich ihn nicht kenne, zeigt auch, wie klein seine Rolle ist. Weil er nicht zu Konferenzen geht und so. Es gibt halt diesen wohlwollenden Diktator.
Das heißt, die Community muss im Prinzip erst einmal noch ihre eigenen Modelle entwickeln, wohin die Reise geht. Das ist natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch super interessant. Wir haben es hier mit einer Plattform zu tun, die auf jeden Fall zukunftsträchtig ist. Ich denke, das lässt sich mit Bestimmtheit sagen, weil JavaScript wird nicht weggehen. Das hat einfach die größte installierte Base von einem Programmiersprachen überhaupt. Das kann man eigentlich so festhalten, wenn auch nur in Browsern anführungsstrichen das nur. Aber es fehlt eigentlich an Leuten, die dieses Potential auch mal richtig erschließen. Man sieht ja, was so Anwendungen wie Google Maps für einen Unterschied machen können. Was das auf einmal für eine Dynamik freisetzt, sowohl im Web als eben auch für dahinter stehende Dienstleistung. Das ist jetzt mal so ganz prophetisch von mir ohnegeworfen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die Sicht so teilst.
Es ist ja so viel größer eigentlich. Die Anzahl der Anwendungen, die mit JavaScript gebaut werden, sind ja im Wesentlichen heute die Menge aller Web-Anwendungen zusammen. Die haben wir alle JavaScript. Der Anwendungsraum ist ja riesengroß. Deswegen ist sicher auch Raum dafür, dass sich in verschiedenen Kontexten, um die Frameworks herum, so verschiedene Anwendungsarten bündeln. Also ein Riesenthema ist zum Beispiel, wie lade ich JavaScript in den Browser? Der Trend des letzten Jahres ist sowieso Ladezeitenoptimierung. Weil man dachte ja so, ok, Internetverbindungen werden immer schneller. Ist völlig egal. Forschung zeigt, dass genau das Gegenteil der Fall ist. Die Erwartungshaltung der Nutzer über Ladezeiten von Websites ist so, dass sie immer schneller wollen. Es kommen so abstruse Faktoren, dass je schneller eine Seite antwortet, desto länger halten sich die Leute darauf auf. Und je schneller sie lädt, desto höher ist der durchschnittliche Umsatz in e-Commerce-Websites und so. Und dadurch ist es halt so ein Thema. Und JavaScript, wenn man es naiv verwendet, führt halt zu einer extremen Verlangsamung der Ladezeiten von Seiten. Das liegt überhaupt nicht daran, dass es viel JavaScript wäre, sondern es liegt daran, dass ein Browser, das sind alle Implementierungen gleich, in dem Moment, wo man einen Script-Hack sieht mit einer externen Source, lädt er diese Datei runter und führt dann erst, macht dann erst weiter mit dem Parsen des Dokuments und fängt vor allem auch dann erst an, die Bilder runterzuladen. Wenn ich jetzt ein HTML-Dokument habe, wo ich oben erstmal 10 Script-Hacks habe, dann werden die komplett krass seriell downgeloadet und das dauert, egal wie schnell meine Internetverbindung ist, auf jeden Fall mal so lange wie, das dauert so 10 TCPI-Connections durchzubören und das ist halt lang. Und da gibt es dann halt eine unglaubliche große Trickkiste an Tools, wie ich das optimieren kann. Also das ganz einfache ist, dass ich auf dem Server einfach die Dateien, die ich sonst nacheinander hätte, in eine große tue. Das ist oft auch der beste Ansatz, dass ich erst am Ende des Dokumentes, also kurz vor dem schließenden Buddy-Tech, meinen Script lade, damit schon mal die Request für die ganzen anderen Bilder und CSS-Dateien so losgeschickt werden konnten. Dann ganz krass auch das Inlining von JavaScript. Dann gibt es so Loader, die AJAX nutzen, also XML hat eine Peer-Request, um JavaScript zu laden, was halt asynchron ist. Dann kann man alle Dateien gleichzeitig anfordern.
Das heißt, man nutzt selber JavaScript-Code als Trampolin, um dann anderen JavaScript-Code dazu zu laden.
Minimalen Bootstrap-Code, um halt dieses Laden zu können. Das ist zum Beispiel Lab.js, ein sehr cooles Framework, das halt nur dieses eine Ding kann, nämlich Loading, wo man halt Dependencies noch modellieren kann. Weil, sobald ich asynchron bin beim Laden und ich habe Dependencies mit meinem Code untereinander, wird es ja interessant, in welche Reihenfolge die dann evaluiert werden und so weiter. Das ist dann aber halt auch ätzend wiederum, wenn ich das dann muss ich ja mit Ival ausführen, ist für das Debugging nicht so cool. Da gibt es halt, da kann man sehr, sehr, sehr viel Zeit damit verbringen, das richtig zu machen.
Ja, damit bringst du mich jetzt eigentlich auch schon auf die letzten beiden Punkte. Weil ich denke, jetzt haben wir eigentlich im Wesentlichen inhaltlich das erstmal alles ganz gut abgedeckt. Werkzeuge und Ressourcen würden mich jetzt noch interessieren. Also gibt es schon brauchbare Entwicklungsumgebungen für JavaScript, die einem Arbeit abnehmen? Was würdest du da empfehlen? Gibt es da etabliertes oder hat da auch jeder seinen eigenen Ansatz?
Also es gibt welche. Ich kann jetzt auch, ich antworte jetzt nicht mit VI. Aber selbst verwende ich halt TextMate, was mir ja nicht besonders viel hilft dabei.
Also normaler Texteditor auf dem Mac.
Ich finde es ganz, also ich lerne halt APIs gern auswendig, dann kennt man die wenigstens. Aber das Klassische, es gibt halt keine Type, also anders. Es gibt so Ansätze, dass man halt zu Type-Annotations macht in Kommentarform. Vor allem haben wir heute noch nicht darüber gesprochen, es gibt ja den Google Closure Compiler. Closure ist ein Framework von Google, was auch das Gleiche macht wie Dojo, YUI und so weiter, auch ziemlich groß ist. Und der Closure Compiler, da kann man halt Type-Annotations in den Quellcode schreiben in Kommentaren, die der dann nutzt, um den Quellcode noch weiter optimieren zu können, indem man sozusagen das, was der Tracing-JIT erst durch Induktion irgendwie herausfindet, einfach schon mal hinschreibt.
Das heißt, er ist ein Compiler, der aus JavaScript JavaScript baut.
Ja, dass es nur schneller ist als vorher.
Ah, verstehe.
Und wenn ich diese Type-Annotations habe, dann kann ich natürlich so Sachen wie Code Completion anbieten. Wenn ich da hinschreibe, da kommt jetzt ein Hund, dann kann ich dann irgendwie Punkt machen, und dann kann mir jemand anbieten, welche Methoden dieser Hund hat. Aber das passt halt gar nicht in JavaScript, weil der kann ja vielleicht auch noch andere Sachen können, dieser Hund. Das kann ich ja gar nicht schattlich hinschreiben, selbst wenn ich. Aber da gibt es natürlich irgendwie einen Markt für, aber da kann ich keine Antwort darauf geben. Das kenne ich nicht.
Entwicklungswerkzeuge meinst du jetzt? Ich weiß nicht, ich habe jetzt auch gar nichts im Kopf. Ich glaube, das Xcode-Environment von Apple kommt auch mit so einem Dashcode, was so auf JavaScript-Development gemacht ist. Und es gibt natürlich auch so diverse Debugging-Möglichkeiten in den Browsern mittlerweile auch. Also ich glaube, das hat eine Farie.
Gut, da habe ich jetzt nicht dran gedacht, aber das ist schon ein wichtiger Punkt. Was auch natürlich das Arbeiten mit der Sprache auch wieder revolutioniert hat, war vor allem Firebug, das Next-Session für Firefox, wo man halt so Dinge tun kann, wie Breakpoints setzen und so. Also ein ganz klassischer Debugger ist das, um mit dem JavaScript-Quelcode zu arbeiten. Und da gibt es in den WebKit-Browsern jeweils auch eine Implementierung, auch ein JavaScript-Debugger. Und im EE8 ist auch einer drin, was ganz cool ist, weil da sind die Sachen ja als Web-Entwickler meistens auch kaputt. Und dann kann man sie auch daheim machen. Und dann gibt es halt Profiling-Tools. Da gibt es auch einen, fast das Beste, ist Dynatrace Ajax Edition. Das ist eine Erweiterung für EE. Und die zeigt halt auch JavaScript-Passzeiten und so, wenn man da optimieren will, bis auf API-Call-Ebene im Browser. Und halt auch wieder in dem Browser, wenn man da alles schnell hat, dann braucht man sich an Chrome keine Sorgen mehr machen.
Das heißt, das ist mehr schon ein Performance-Tool.
Ja, das ist ein Performance-Tool. Weil, wie gesagt, Web-Performance ist wirklich ein Riesenthema. Ja, glaube ich. Das auch wirklich den ganzen Markt ein bisschen belebt hat, weil es gibt halt super viele Web-Agenturen, die irgendwie Internetseiten machen können. Aber im Augenblick ist es halt, so schnelle Webseiten zu bauen, ist halt voll schwer und deswegen auch interessant.
Wenn man sich jetzt dem Thema komplett neu zuwenden möchte, JavaScript, was würdest du denn so als Einstiegsresource empfehlen? Gibt es Lieblingsbücher oder...
Also, was man sich antun kann, wenn man sich so ein bisschen an Bacchus-Nauer-Formen nicht stört, dann ist sicher interessant das Buch von Douglas Crockford, JavaScript, the good parts. Douglas hat eine sehr klare Meinung dazu, welche Teile von JavaScript man besser nicht verwenden sollte. Da bin ich nicht komplett deckungsgleich mit ihm, aber im Wesentlichen hat er recht. Das ist ein sehr theoretisches Buch, das sich wirklich nur mit diesen Sprach-Features auseinandersetzt. Da kann man hinterher keine Website bauen. Man kann da wirklich nur mit JavaScript-Programmen hinterherkommen. Programmen bringt es natürlich auch nicht bei.
Also ein bisschen know your enemy. Und um überhaupt erst mal den Einstieg zu finden, scheint mir ja schon eher der zweite Schritt zu sein. Das ist ein O'Reilly-Buch, es gibt ja auch noch ein anderes O'Reilly-Buch, was seit langem verkauft wird zu JavaScript.
Ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht, das kenne ich aber nicht. Dann von John Raysick, Secrets of a JavaScript Ninja. Das habe ich auch noch nicht gelesen. Da bin ich aber ganz sicher, dass es cool ist, weil ich viele Ausschritte gelesen habe, die er veröffentlicht hat. Ich glaube, da ist man schon ganz gut dabei. Und wenn man wirklich keine Ahnung hat, dann ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt, dich mit JQuery zu beschäftigen.
Einfach so als Standarduniversalframework.
Genau, weil es halt sozusagen doch eine sehr, sehr kurze Lernkurve hat, um halt irgendwie coole Sachen zu machen. Und dann musst du irgendwie von da weiter gucken.
Und wenn man sich jetzt so an die Community andocken möchte und vielleicht erstmal nicht die Möglichkeit hat, zu der Konferenz zu kommen oder vielleicht auch nicht so lange warten möchte.
Die sind sich aber immer gleich ausverkauft.
Gibt es da irgendwelche Leute, wie viele Leute nehmen daran teil?
Also wir hatten jetzt in Berlin 200, absolute Obergrenze war für uns. Und in den USA haben die Begrenzung sogar noch kleiner gehalten. Also eher so 150 Leute.
Das ist ja schon ein sehr elitärer Zirkel.
Ja, was sicher seine Vor- und Nachteile hat. Aber es formieren sich so ein bisschen User Groups. In Hamburg habe ich das immer noch nicht geschafft, mal ein Meeting zu machen. Aber wenn ich irgendwie dran bin, in Berlin gibt es auch erst seit ganz kurzem eine, wo dann auch wirklich zu diesen User Group-Treffen mehr Leute kommen als zur Konferenz.
Was, über 200 Leute?
Ja, vielleicht nicht ganz so. Normalerweise sind es User Groups eher so zehn Leute. Das ist ja schon ein Hype-Thema, da kommen so User Groups immer viele Leute. Da gibt es dann irgendwie Vorträge und Videos von denen teilweise. Das ist aber mehr noch eine amerikanische Sache. Und sonst findet natürlich, wie in jeder Programmiesprache, die Community in den Mailing-List rund um die Frameworks und so weiter statt.
Bei denen der User Group trifft sich im Co-op-Working-Space.
Ich kenne das, da ist nicht Platz für 200, aber ein paar Leute passen schon rein.
Ja, das heißt, man muss sich schon richtig anstellen, um am Halbteil zu dürfen. Das ist ja schon fast wie eine Steve Jobs Keynote hier.
Ja, es ist halt, da es am Augenblick niemanden gibt, der das monetarisiert, den Hype. Also es gibt ja keine 37 Signals.
Also keine Webseite, die jetzt irgendwie, so wie damals Rails sozusagen so populär im Mittelpunkt steht.
Genau, und die das irgendwie treibt. Dadurch ist es halt eine viel mehr so, eine Open-House-Community, die funktioniert halt irgendwie, so wie sie halt gerade Bock hat. Und das ist in jedem Framework ein bisschen anders. Also Dojo hat eine super Organisation, wo es andauernd Meetups auf der ganzen Welt gibt, wo auch so die Framework-Autoren versuchen hinzufliegen und so. Wer John Razik von jQuery kennt, weiß, dass das mit so persönlich da nicht so einfach ist. Aber dafür ist da halt einfach eine riesige Community drumherum, weil das wirklich, denke ich mal, jetzt so ein Marktanteil von 60, 70 Prozent von neuen Projekten bestimmt damit verbaut werden.
Ja, Malte, haben wir irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen?
Ich glaube nicht. War ja relativ ausführlich.
Ja, das war's. War jetzt auch eine schön lange Sendung. Aber das hatte ich eigentlich auch so im Sinne. Nicht, dass uns einer vorwirft, wir hätten irgendwas vergessen. Haben wir aber wahrscheinlich trotzdem. Und ja, wenn ihr es mal wieder besser wisst oder noch sonstige Fragen habt, dann marschiert doch mal in das Blog, blog.chaos.radio.cc.de, wo auch zu dieser Sendung wieder ein Eintrag schlummert. Malte wird da sicherlich auch nochmal ein bisschen reinschauen, falls ein paar kluge Fragen kommen. Ja, und dann gucken wir mal, was da so passiert. Ich persönlich bin da sehr gespannt und erwartungsvoll, also einerseits getrieben durch diesen mobilen Markt, der jetzt so ganz neue Aspekte aufbringt, aber auch überhaupt die ganzen Bewegungen. Ich meine, mit diesen ganzen neuen Implementierungen, das haben wir ja hier auch schon ansatzweise gesprochen, zeichnet sich einfach ab, dass da halt einfach mal wieder eine komplett neue Plattform entsteht, die durchaus jetzt im Hinblick auf Performance nicht unbedingt unüberwindliche Hürden aufstellt, sondern das läuft alles schon ganz flüssig, eben gepaart mit dem Vorteil einer unfassbaren Verbreitung, die wir eben heute einfach schon in der Welt haben. Ich bin gespannt. Wäre auch sozusagen mal wieder ein neuer Durchbruch für eine funktionale und dynamische Premiere-Sprache, liegt mir auch immer sehr im Herzen. Aber darum soll es ja jetzt gar nicht gehen, sondern hier ging es um JavaScript und das war's. Vielen Dank, Malte. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ich freue mich auf eure Kommentare und Anmerkungen zu dieser Sendung. Wie immer, und ich freue mich vor allem auch, wenn ihr künftig wieder zuschaltet, wenn ihr mich dann am Ende der Sendung sagen hört. Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express. Auf Wiedersehen!